okay it is um 1103 uh I would like to uh
convene a work session on House Bill 49
for those of you who uh are are just
sort of Dipping into this issue for the
first time House Bill 49 is uh
interconnected in many ways to
um a much larger issue which is what are
we going to do about the sununu youth
development center
in legislation a couple years ago we
passed into law that we must close the
sununu center on one March and so we're
now just about three three weeks and a
few days away from that and so there are
three separate bills that are kind of
live in the system
HP 49 is one of them I'm a prime sponsor
um and and what it does is it it
currently moves out the dates through
the rest of the fiscal year there's also
a an HP 120
that is a more comprehensive bill that's
very close to what was done by the
committee conference nearly two years
ago it is being worked by the children
in family law I ex I expect that it's
probably going to be retained there for
a while and then the other one that's
very live and in finance and getting
scheduled is sb1 it's a pretty
comprehensive Bill to replace the sununu
center
and provides some design criteria so
that the architectural firms and the
people who do operational planning can
start to do do some serious analysis and
get to work
so that passed the Senate 24 to nothing
and it's in the the hands of Finance
we're going to have our first finance
committee on that on the ninth so so I
talk about those three because I want
you to everyone could we hand these out
there's we're going to pass a graphic
around that basically visualizes of much
of what I just said but but
um so so this is uh this is House Bill
I think
um
Mr Ripple on House Bill 49 are there
copies for the audience
okay
so
so this is this is this is our first
discussion in official committee on
house bill 49 and the sununu replacement
Center and we'll talk about the sununu
replacement bill
as we talk about some amendments uh I
don't think we're going to take any
formal votes today at least certainly
not until
representative nordgren can be here she
she's she's not going to come at all
today so it's a no formal votes and then
you know representative stringham's not
here so today is is is pretty much going
to be discussion I might take some straw
votes though representative walner just
to get a sense of where people are at
nothing that is binding in any way or or
really determinative for what we advise
the finance committee of our position
but just in case we we need the sense of
where we're at
so that's a very long intro but then I
didn't gavel so but we're we're now
we're now in session uh and uh
representative whole do you have a
question I do I'm looking at this
graphic
and I appreciate whoever threw this out
but yeah that was me I was an analyst I
was never a graphic artist that's okay
um broken is clear as a word is that
attempt is the next word it's not real
clear what how that reads
okay so photocopies so as you read from
left to right the the left hand column
where it says RSA close the sysc and
then the committee conference those are
two actions that happened pretty much at
around the same time the result of those
things those two things is that we came
up with a badly broken process from a
legislative perspective we we had
determined that the sununu center would
close and we determined that we had no
idea what the replacement would look
like this is this is a backwards process
where normally if you want to close
something you would do the planning to
figure out what the the replacement
would be and then you do the transition
planning from the old to the new we
didn't do that so so there there is I'm
sure frustration abounding that uh we've
got some bad process here but I think
this legislature inherited a a broken
situation and and now we're trying to
repair it knowing that if you go to the
right of that sheet of paper that one
March 2023 deadline is you know in the
military we would say danger close we
need we need to really be focused on
that
so
um
in this work session should I should I
be introducing HP 49 we're just talking
about it does everyone have a copy of
hb49 I don't I don't think I have a copy
of hb49
do I
okay I do
does everyone on the committee have a
copy okay uh everyone in the audience
that wants a copy do you have a copy
raise your hand if you don't have a copy
and you really want a copy okay so we're
good
um and then for those that are doing the
the YouTube
um Mr Ripple uh they can get to House
Bill 49 just through the general court
looking at the bill search under hb49 is
that correct yes okay so this is a very
short bill it's only got 10 lines
um it essentially uh extends the date of
closure from the 1st of March until the
end of the fiscal year this fiscal year
which is June 30th that's essentially
four months so we're this this would buy
us some time and then uh the
appropriation the second part is because
we're going to keep it open for an
additional four months there was a need
to put some monies against it and the
1.5 million was sort of an Edwards uh
finger in the air kind of estimate that
I I have since verbally confirmed with
the Department is not a horrible guess
and we'll get we can get some testimony
on that and so this is a kind of a kick
that can buy some time as soon as this
gets signed by the governor it would
immediately go into effect that's what
HP 49 does
um or is there any discussion on 49 any
amendments that we're going to offer on
49 representative hole
thank you Mr chairman
um whoever's testifying relative to
section two in terms of the costs can
they figure it out at a per month rate
for us as well so let's say June 30th
isn't the magic date that we want to
move this out let's say we choose I
don't know September 30th to pick a
number out of the air or a date out of
the air right that number is going to
directly impact section two so if we can
get information at a like 1 12th of the
operating budget per month we can then
do the math uh yes sir I think the ripe
ripe time to talk about that was if
there's an amendment that pushes the
closure date out Beyond this fiscal year
but yes yes sir I would be willing to
offer an amendment
to that effect if necessary and the
reason I was
I have seen enough enough legislation
that gets passed in the July August time
frame that August 30th might be
reasonable because historically the
bills work their way through even if
it's an expedited Bill takes a little
bit of time to get to the governor's
desk and there's no reason to try and
hamper this by days when we know all the
bills will be processed in time for a
veto session in September so if there
was two more months to this I shoot that
one so when you say you offer an
amendment are you offering a suggestion
for an amendment or do you have a an OLS
uh unapproved draft of an amendment uh I
am offering a suggestion for an
amendment at this point yes sir okay do
we have any OLS documentation on an
amendment that we want to consider
representative walner
well I do have a I do have a couple of
amendments I do want to know if we're
going to have an opportunity to talk
about uh the appropriation that is in
Hospital
yes okay good and I do have a couple of
amendments do you want to do that before
we discuss either of your amendments
get to just verify this amount
thank you I just have a comment and I
know that I am playing catch up on the
education factor of this whole topic
um but I guess I question
the four-month extension if we have no
place for them to go on March 1st where
are the children going to go on June
30th and is this a little short-sighted
intern I get and again maybe I'm wrong
in my understanding of the situation
I'm looking at who the prime sponsor is
and and I'd say that guy is usually
pretty short-sighted so so no what this
was if you if you look at the graph
the the picture you know just to help
put 49 into context when I sent this
into OLS back in November or September I
think it was September actually uh I
didn't know what the future would be I
didn't know how we would be sitting here
today and all this did was it recognized
that something was broken and that we
might need to and you'll notice that I I
headlined it by time
that that purchase of time was sort of a
a an ability for us to have more
discussion if we needed to on what the
real answer is so this was just intended
to buy us some time if we got into a
rock and a hard place and and we're kind
of there
so so it is short-sighted but it was
intentionally short-sighted thinking it
was just enough time for us to decide
what we really wanted to do
that was the intent okay
so so Mr ribson do you have a follow-up
representative
okay okay that's okay I will continue to
absorb the information and my questions
might be answered as we go okay uh Miss
ribson could you come up introduce
yourself
well I think we all know you but
and and and let's let's keep this
distinct the the first thing I I want to
do is I want to address just what's in
HP 49 and and then we can lift our eyes
up and and talk longer term but first
let's just stay on 49. great good
morning everybody Joe ripson director of
dcyf uh thank you for having me here
thank you for hearing from me and happy
to discuss any aspect of this that the
committee would like to discuss
okay so I'll I'll start you off with a
question then on
um on HP 49 lines five through nine
there's an appropriation for 1.5 million
to get us through the four months uh
that we would add from the first of
March to the end of June uh tell us tell
us your thoughts your professional
judgment about the adequacy of uh that
1.5 million dollar wedge yes so last
biennium the appropriation to operate
sysc was struck at about 10.4 million
dollars per year
that included about roughly in 2023 1.4
million dollars of what was called other
funds sysc for folks that aren't
familiar is not allowed to operate with
federal funds Medicaid and things like
that are not allowed to be used under
current law for facilities like this
although good news folks might not
realize is this yet there is a change in
federal law in a couple years where you
are going to be allowed to use Medicaid
to support detained youth for treatment
purposes it's not exactly clear how far
that will spread if it's just for the
actual individual treatment episodes of
kids and stuff but there will be some
relief on that coming in a couple years
I want to be careful not to make
everyone think that half of the cost is
suddenly going to be federally absorbed
I don't think that's how far it'll go
but there will be some some relief
coming there
um anyway
um the 1.4 million dollars in other
funds there's a couple things
um that have happened since then so as
everybody's aware we've had some real
challenges of sysc with Staffing caused
by a few different things number one
real massive shifts in Workforce that
have hit Health and Human Services
across the board but particularly
Residential Care particularly a facility
like sysc where wages no longer were
competitive with what people can make in
retail fast food or anywhere else we did
make some efforts to try to improve
wages with enhancements and stuff but it
simply wasn't enough to keep Pace the
other big thing that happened of course
that has been discussed many many times
in this legislature was the inability to
come to some type of plan for the future
leaving the future of sysc in limbo and
leaving a closure date on the books
where staff kind of gave up and figured
they weren't going to have a future and
started looking for other jobs so we got
to a point where a facility that really
requires 45 front line staff to run got
down to 20 Front Line staff and got into
a real crisis
um when that happened we could no longer
continue to run what was a contract with
the state of Vermont to serve their
youth that is where a lot of those other
funds were anticipated to come from so
we were no longer able to bring in these
other funds to operate the facility so
we lost a revenue stream that we were
operating in the past
that also required us to really really
ramp up overtime in the facility and
actually required me to mandate Juvenile
Justice probation and parole officers to
start covering shifts in the facility in
order to keep it safe
um that's run up over time dramatically
too and those staff make a lot more
money than YC's than our youth
counselors do so that's ran up costs
pretty dramatically
we when we kind of did the ran the
numbers and figured out kind of what the
burn rate was we think it's about 1.6
million that we're going to end up short
by the end of the year you know whether
that's done through an appropriation
here through some type of departmental
transfer through joint fiscal at some
point but we do think we're going to
have some type of challenge in that
ballpark that we're keeping an eye on
right now
um representative Holz good point about
the fact that you're going to have a
potential issue if the facility stays
open longer I think that is true
although I also Imagine that's something
that could be addressed through the
typical budget process you know assuming
that you would if you would continue
operating the budget or operating
facility the next fiscal year you would
anticipate the costs for that in your
next fiscal year budget
uh thank you for that I I'm looking for
a kind of a bottom line yes no kind of
thing here uh yes we in hb2 estimates
1.5 million needed for the four
additional months
is that a good estimate or did I just
hear you say you think it really ought
to be 1.6 million I think 1.5 is good we
1.6 is what we came up with but there's
also
at any given time the truth is there's
contracts out there for example that we
know we're not going to be paid in full
right so we have for example a contract
with Dartmouth to provide Clinical
Services that funds a part-time
psychiatrist a part-time psychologist
and two clinicians they've not been able
to fill the second clinician so we're
not going to be we're not going to pay
that for that clinician right and that's
about a hundred thousand dollars right
there so
the way that our budgeting works that
contract currently appears as encumbered
so that hundred thousand dollars shows
up as being spent but I also know at the
end of the fiscal year we're not going
to spend a hundred thousand dollars
because that clinician wasn't working so
while our on the books we're showing 1.6
it probably is really 1.5 because I know
we're not going to spend 100 000 on the
clinician that hasn't shown up
thank you any questions
so
do you have any figures on how much you
have spent on overtime not with me but I
can get that and what is the vacancy
rate at
the sununu center
right now in terms of Youth counselors
It's it's dry I think we have 45
positions on something at this point
like 17 filled
45 and 45 positions with something like
17 filled we do have temp staff there
which makes it a little bit better but I
wouldn't count them in our account
um and we have some of that 17 actually
wasn't turnover since the 20 it was
actually a couple folks were promoted to
supervisory roles which is good really
since the conversation says he have
heated up about kind of a future State
and people have gotten a little more
hope we haven't seen people leaving the
facility which is good we've had one
person leave but that was to a
promotional opportunity to become a jppo
and I don't really consider that you
know that's that's career growth it
wasn't like an exodus
so things have kind of stabilized in
terms of people leaving but trying to
get people to come in has been really
hard because they they don't really see
a future and you know again the wage
issue is still a challenge I am hopeful
on that front you know the the current
negotiations
um in terms of collective bargaining
agreement seem pretty promising and I
think we'll be in a better position come
July 1 on that but right now that the
wage issue is also a challenge in terms
of recruiting staff
okay
um have you and you have used some
incentives to get people there what can
you just really quickly tell me there
was yeah there was one incentive program
which was a retention incentive program
where if staff stayed for a period of
six months the guy I think it was about
a thousand dollars that that program has
expired and in fact a lot of Staff left
anyway during that period
there is another incentive currently in
place that was approved by joint fiscal
for a staff who work 24 hours of
overtime in a pay period they receive an
extra 300 on top of the time and a half
that they would ordinarily receive that
has been well received and a lot of
people are working a lot of overtime
which is great to keep the facilities
safe but it also Burns people out over
time right
um and there's a another Statewide
incentive in terms of being able to
anytime you can recruit a state employee
there's kind of a bonus for the person
who does the Recruitment and a bonus for
the person who gets recruited and stays
on board for 90 days we actually haven't
seen that result in any kind of movement
in terms of sysc recruitment but we have
seen that kind of have some some
movement on the child protection side of
dcyf great thank you yep
um I just I want to keep my numbers
straight the first time I heard you you
talk about the number of direct care
providers in contact with the residents
you said that you you're authorized 45
and you only had 25 of them but then the
second time
you said 17. so so is it 17 20 or 25.
I've never said 25 I don't think we have
20 we had 20 we're now down to 17
because we had two that promoted up to
supervisors okay and one that left to
become a jppo okay so the implication of
that 17 of the 45 is that should you
have a tremendously High vacancy rate uh
a scary one yes and so for all of those
people in the community that would like
to see uh the sununu center
transitioning to a trauma-informed
therapeutic environment
the ability to do that I'm guessing
would be
very limited you know just because
training takes time you're going to
invest in training you want people to
stick around what what can you tell us
about where you are and what you think
about transitioning the current program
to a trauma-informed therapeutic
environment great good question the yeah
so if we look at you know sb1 or even
the bill that was passed last year hb120
all of them anticipate a host of
programming changes even the audit that
happened a couple years ago right moving
to evidence-based models stuff that
we're actually positioned to do in terms
of our clinical team our psychologist
down there has identified kind of ready
to go but all of them are highly
dependent on having a stable milieu
Workforce Frontline Workforce that knows
your kids and who can be trained to use
these models and when you have a
Workforce like we have right now where
you have you know 17 core staff of 45
and everybody else is kind of just
floating in for six hours here or there
you can never really Implement a model
like that because they're all wholly
dependent on knowing your kids being
able to anticipate their behaviors and
redirect and you don't you just can't do
that if you don't know your kids and you
can't know your kids if you don't spend
a lot of time with them it's really as
simple as that so as long as we're in
this position of limbo I do fear that
we're not going to be able to make that
next step that next transition into
being able to effectively Implement
evidence-based trauma-informed
programming so let's come back to that
next step you know the the obviously the
community consensus around this is that
we want a trauma-informed therapeutic
model
um but I I think what you let us know is
that all of those changes in that
mission and that methodology are in
bills that have not yet passed and that
if you went to the current statutes you
don't have anything from the legislature
or the governor telling you that you
shall be providing a trump-based
therapeutic model is that true
correct I think we do have an audit
saying that we should be doing these
things and we have responded to that
audit saying that we're trying but we've
not been able to implement for the for
these reasons
oh okay so it would still be helpful I
think to have the legislative intent for
you to transition uh representative Holt
did you have a question
thank you
a number of uh several numbers were
given to me and since I'm taking notes
can you provide those in written form
both for Staffing and costs
um and in in particular the retention
bonus I did not capture all that
information
so like the if some if a staff member
works so many hours there's a bonus on
top of the hourly rate it's 300 for 24
hours over two weeks over a pay period
but would you like an email with that
yeah if you can just summarize all of
those
that would be great thank you
do you have a question
representative Mooney and then
representative Wallner
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here today we've heard a lot about
the Staffing which is very helpful of
course but what about the juvenile
residents how many are there now and
what is your projection for enrollment
by the end of June I know that's hard to
estimate with people coming and going
thank you
sure today the census is 12.
I have here some charts
should be enough for the committee
folks if you want
uh Mr Ripple is bringing around a chart
that has the sysc daily population from
July 20 from July 1 2016 through
um the start of this year January 1 2023
. as I said today's census is 12 but the
census varies radically over time you do
see back in 2016 the census often was in
the 70s up to about 75 at times you also
see kind of a real giant decline between
2016 and 2019 and there were a couple
big things that have been happening
during that time you had
changes in the law as to who could be
detained and committed and you also had
the Advent of the children's system of
care so we started creating alternative
community-based programs to try to work
with kids in their behavioral health
care needs to prevent them from having
to come into the system also in the past
year we implemented what we call our
Juvenile Justice assessment process
whereby whenever kids have contact with
law enforcement we now use a child
adolescent needs and strengths tool to
determine do they even need to go to
court or is this a kid that has some
type of challenge that we can meet in
the community without them even going to
court in the first place so we have lots
of efforts to try to keep kids out that
have gotten this census down much
further than where it used to be
if you look at this chart does everybody
have it now yeah the green at the top is
the total
the red line is the detained population
the blue line is the committed
population you see those two numbers
kind of crisscross each other pretty
frequently the census has kind of peaked
because we have new members on the
committee that have not dealt with the
definitions of detain and committed
could you just give us a very short
definition I can so a detained youth
typically means a young person who has
been arrested and is pending court right
they've and under law to to be detained
you have to have committed a relatively
serious offense in New Hampshire
um
so typically that means that they're
pending court but within that population
and typically that means it's a
relatively short period of time but
there are some some offenses for which
that population could be there for a
long time and that typically when I say
that that's normally young people who
are there pending adult charges so if
you come in and act like murder and
you're pending adult charges you could
be there for a very long time on a
detained status because those charges
you'll end up going through like a
process to determine whether you can be
tried as an adult and then another full
those Trials take a long time they
they'll end up in a detained status for
a very long time and then even if they
end up being convicted they'll remain
with us until they turn 18. so those
young people in our books anyway they'll
still show up as a detained youth
throughout the entirety of their stay
with us the other category that'll show
up in our numbers as a detained youth is
what's called an icj a uh
um
interstate compact for juvenile youth
that's when a youth from another state
gets arrested in New Hampshire that
could be a youth who's arrested in New
Hampshire for committing a crime in New
Hampshire or it could be a youth who has
a warrant from another state who gets
arrested in New Hampshire and gets held
in New Hampshire pending return to their
home state
those numbers also show up in the
detained numbers but the typical
detained youth it's a short-term stay
either pending their hearing
sometimes just pending a preliminary
hearing so it could often just be 24
hours or a couple days and other times
it might be a couple weeks you know
pending their uh adjudicatory hearing
and then you have the committed
population which is a post hearing a
judge determines that they should be
committed to the facility and committed
youth are sent for two sentences you
know if it's a a more serious offense it
could be six months and then parole if
it's a less serious offense although
like I said you know in New Hampshire
it's a pretty pretty high bar compared
to other states to be committed at all
it's three months and then parole or
then you're eligible for parole you know
they could decide the parole board could
determine that you're not ready to be
released at that point but the typical
length of stay for a young person who's
committed really is about three months
it's unusual for committed youth to to
not make parole
um it does happen but it's not typical
so again if we look at the chart you do
see kind of that detained and committed
population bounce up and down
um over the past really since the start
of 2020 when you did see we were over 20
youth we've never really exceeded 18
youth since that time
the lowest we've gotten was five total
Youth and that was actually in November
of this year
the highest we've gotten was 18 Youth
and that was two not even two weeks ago
so the census can swing radically
quickly so you know if we're talking
about projections for June I don't see
June as being any different than what
we've seen for the past two or three
years in terms of you know we could be
at 18 or we could be at five but we
would be somewhere in that range the
other variables in there that you have
to consider is you know male and female
um you know typically the female
population is relatively low for the
past year we've had rarely had more than
one female at a time in the building but
we did have a period
for the first time I think in the
history of the facility not this past
October the prior October where there
were eight females in the building and
only six males so we actually had a time
where there were more females than males
for I think the first time ever
so there are there are shifts in the
census and population that are that are
unpredictable do you have a follow-up
okay okay I'm getting ready to go to
representative Wallner but I I just have
a quick question on the icjs
um
can can you this feels like a very small
number uh of the of the detained but
could you give us some idea of of the
type of typical arrests because I I
would think it would be very rare that
New Hampshire would want to arrest a kid
from out of state to hold them for
transfer so what what kind of what kind
of cases are those generally it's it is
rare
um probably only happens maybe three or
four times a year
um you know the most recent one was out
of Massachusetts and it was you know
some serious gang-related offenses you
know um violence and and narcotics
uh thank you representative walner did
you still have a question I did and just
I'm sorry just to go back just to finish
the icj conversation uh the compact
requires that the sen that the state uh
the state of origin must retrieve the
child within five days although
typically it's faster than that I think
it's five days because the idea that
perhaps they're coming from all the way
across the country although I don't
think we've actually seen any of that
it's normally the neighboring states
good clarification thank you go ahead
representative walner
since we aren't going to be able to
predict what the future is going to hold
as far as
this employment situation I mean it's
not just it's not just at the sununu
center it's all across every employer
you talk to is having a hard time hiring
people and I I mean I don't know I have
no idea what the what's going to happen
um so we might anticipate that hiring
people to work at a facility is going to
continue to be a struggle
and wouldn't we also at the same time
that we're trying to look at
having enough people
to care for the kids wouldn't we be
looking at further ways of reducing the
number of children who are in the
facility
so that
the you're 17
would have a more appropriate number of
children to be cared for yeah I think we
should yeah I mean I think we should
always be looking at and I think we are
actively always looking at ways to
reduce the number of children right so
you know I described the work that we're
doing through what was SB 94 I've talked
about the work we're doing with the
system of care not in as much detail as
I could part of the system of care work
is the use of something that's fairly
new which is the use of Care Management
entities so those are those are groups
who you do Behavioral Health Care work
they use a high fidelity wraparound
model to help work with families to be
able to transition kids to their next
step kids that get detained and
committed to sysc are on the priority
list to get a care manager identified
for them immediately and quickly so that
they could help transition those kids
out as quickly as possible sometimes
that's a step down to a residential
program sometimes that's back to the
community so we're doing a lot of work
to try to get these kids out I think
what I would what I would say to that
though is I do you think that we can get
this census down I don't think there's a
lot of precedent anywhere in the country
to get much lower than we are though
and I did bring copies of report if
folks are interested that shows that
we're already
the second lowest number of detained
kids in the country and the second
lowest number of committed kids in the
country and we are the lowest combined
detained and committed
census in the country
so you know from at least precedence
within this country it's hard to it's
hard to see where there's a whole lot of
room for shrinking although I absolutely
believe that we want to have as few kids
in a detained or committed setting as as
possible
could I just follow up with one further
question about that the report that
you're referring to does it take into
consideration the population of the
states yes I mean because New Hampshire
is a fairly small population yeah it's a
rate
it's a per capita right okay thank you
representative Holt thank you chairman
so
um looking at the numbers currently
right
there are about I don't know seven eight
maybe nine sorry
um four or five that are committed and
then eight nine that are detained
currently in this
do you have the durations for those that
are committed time-wise do you know how
long are these people that are in there
right there
miners who are going to be there through
18 we know that they're going to be
there for a while because of the crimes
they've committed you know the committed
population actually very is not is not
typically there till they're 18. the
only young people who are typically
there until age 18 are the ones who are
there pending adult charges right so we
do have a couple young people who are
there pending adult charges and um you
know our
it's unusual you know it's you know you
hear in other states that you know this
is something that gets taken advantage
of and you have lots of kids you know
locked up through their minority pending
adult charges
um that's not something that I've seen
since I've been here we have two kids
spending adult charges and
um they're they're serious charges that
they're pending
so so I would like to take a timeout
here real quick with the committee
um this is good conversation it's good
context it's going to be useful in other
discussions that we're going to have but
I I think we're I I think what we need
to focus on for a moment is just to make
sure that all your questions relative to
whether or not you think HP 49 is a good
bill or needs to be changed in some way
uh let's let's let's just make sure that
we know what we know about 49 and and
assuming that we might then I would like
to start in bringing forward the any
amendments that there may be 249 so that
we can expand the discussion and then
kind of a orderly way is there anyone
who wants more a representative or
thank you Mr chair so along those lines
of understanding what
we need
if with the current facility you
mentioned that with the evidence-based
trauma informed I believe what you were
saying was
you there was some bills that were
flowing through the system now that had
components of them that addressed those
needs is that first of all is that
accurate is that accurate in my part yes
yeah both Senate bill one and hb120
include language for that yes okay
um you don't do this right now but could
you draw our attention to because
obviously those bills go a lot more than
that in them could you draw could you
let us know which are the components of
those bills that are the pieces you're
talking about that are specific to the
the evidence-based trauma-informed uh
treatment like needs Hood I don't have a
cup and I really want him to to do that
and I I can anticipate him doing it in
about 15 minutes I just want to make
sure that we've moved methodically
through if we if we've got our HP 49
issues identified and if we're ready to
take on the Amendments if I can respond
to that yes sir that's why I asked the
question because
um I see where HP 49
if it says vehicle to get us beyond the
deadline and uh in the past Mr ribson
has mentioned how important it is to get
the evidence-based training going
perhaps those need to be could be
married
oh okay so HP 49 is an extension of four
months and based on their personnel
situation I I don't imagine that they'll
be able to do much other than not get
worse is the goal and just
I I I I I think we need to get to some
discussions around the design components
and model desires
when we begin to talk about amendments
so can can okay so so yes sir do you
have an HP 49 Centric question I do
if I understand correctly there might be
amendments that representative Wallner
has that we could start discussing and
then see amongst those and potentially
others right what's in play to discuss
today
so so you're right representative Waller
I think has two and I have two so we
have we have lots of amendments that we
can discuss and we're not going to come
out of here with any decisions today but
I hopefully we're going to come out of
here smarter so uh do you do you want to
pick one of your amendments and
oh uh I I don't have a copy of your
Amendment do I
I think Kevin does have
copies for everybody okay
um I guess I would
I get I guess I I will bring in
um zero three eleven h
M yeah that's the longer one
these are two numbers I mentioned on the
phone the other day yeah
great thank you uh Mr arlinghaus do you
have a time where you have to leave I
want to respect your time and the fact
that you're here for some specific
testimony
I I I don't I don't want to do that I
I'm I'm I'm I might twist our process a
little bit to get you up here uh so that
your you have some flexibility but
uh all right thank you
go ahead represent Waller well I think
it might be I mean I think it might be
helpful to hear from Mr Arlington
because the amendment that I have before
that I brought in was one that I talked
to um the chairman about yesterday and
it puts the date out by two years and
gives the department
um
I just pulled two million dollars out of
a hat and Mr arlinghaus will be able to
help us with that
um to start the
um architectural design and the
evaluation of the sites so
um
it seems like this might be interesting
to hear from him yes ma'am let's let's
not have you leave Mr ripson uh let's
let's have you become buddies with Mr
arlinghouse because I I I think we're
going to bounce back and forth from one
time to operational
okay we we have more chairs
um I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commission of administrative services
and with me is Ted kupper who's director
of Public Works um
and the can you spell the things I think
we can
add to your list is that um
hold on just one second
um we're gonna we're gonna get to you
very quickly I I want to understand the
intent of the of the amendment uh I uh
the the first items online five and six
are obvious instead of you know moving
this out four months you're proposing
moving it out 28 months but this this is
essentially the status quo this is
without the replacement
until you get to
your appropriation and in the
appropriation you're you're adding more
than is is this two million dollars is
this intended for just this fiscal year
or is this intended between now and 25
and kind of a non-lapsing way
it would be non-lapsing and it would get
it would be available to the department
my idea was to have it available to the
department so they could get started on
site evaluation because we still have
not heard where it's going to be and
some of the architectural consulting
which is where just how I made it up and
the development of design
just just to get them you know so that
they would have some
money to start that process so because
at this point I don't think it's been
started so so if I if I may just more
clarification what what this what your
Amendment does is it which is good in my
view is we're getting them started on
the planning and everything but I don't
see operations money in this so so we
wouldn't they still need operations
money to get through this fiscal year
I had in this amendment I hadn't dealt
with that I had a separate conversation
with the LBA about it and actually Kevin
just handed me a piece of paper that we
can take a look at and maybe he can
explain
where he thinks we are on the spin down
okay based on earlier testimony you're
going to get talking in 20 seconds but
uh based on earlier testimony the 1.5 to
get from through the next four months
appeared to be a good enough estimate
come on
does anyone want new car insurance so
um the 1.5 was enough to get us through
the next four months on an operational
perspective and so if we were to accept
representative Walter's Amendment
wouldn't would wouldn't we need to also
make reference to the 1.5 million of
operation in addition to her
introduction of the two million dollars
for planning
you may and that would be the committee
up to the committee but what I provided
to representative Wallner was a look at
what this was actually spent on the
sununu center in fiscal 22. uh so in
fiscal 22 in total funds uh this new
center spent 9.1 million dollars
their budget in 23 is 9 million of
General funds and another 1 million of
other funds for a total of 10 million
dollars
um as Mr ribson mentioned some of those
other funds may not be available this
fiscal year but what's in the budget
covers what was spent last year I'll put
it that way there may be rising costs
there may be a lack of other funds but
when you say that what's in the budget
do you mean the budget that expires at
the end of June or the budget that
begins July 1.
the budget for fiscal year 23 that we're
currently in contains 10 million dollars
total 9 million General funds and 1
million other funds so as a summary of
your analysis is that the the funds are
already adequate if we just extend the
by four months so we don't need
additional operational money between now
and then I will leave that decision to
you based on what I've provided and I
can provide to you the same paper that I
gave to representative good I'm just
looking for your analysis I have high
faith in your ability to do that but do
do we have enough of your of the of what
you gave representative Waller I'll have
to make copies for the rest of the
committee but I can do that okay well
we'll pause that part
I think we've done enough though to to
introduce A New Concept here is that HB
49 might be improved if we put two
million dollars in so that the
department could begin to do site
evaluation
architectural consultation development
design to look for some options for the
replacement facility and that that money
would be non-lapsing so if we
appropriated it now you could use it
into the next fiscal year so
so with that I think Mr arlinghaus now
you have an opportunity to start talking
about money is is what what is your
reaction to the 2 million to do
um site evaluation which I assume should
include site coordination going out and
talking to the towns and municipalities
site evaluation architectural
consultation and development design for
two at least two options
and the two options that I think we're
going to talk about is a you know on a
Goldilocks model the you know the the
smaller model and the bigger model and
the smaller model maybe six to eight the
bigger model might be 12 to 18. so so
the idea might be that we would ask them
to come up with two designs so that we
have information later to evaluate which
option makes more sense that's a new new
thing for you I know you've not heard
that before but but uh but go ahead well
let me let me start by telling you what
I do know
and it doesn't include the concept of
two designs but
um so let me do that as an addendum
um we have and I will leave with
probably with Kevin with Mr Ripple
um the two sheets of paper for you it it
it happenstance is that we were
called to ask to stop by Senator
Bradley's office yesterday and uh and
present him numbers how much does one of
these things actually cost and so last
night I I sent um
I sent a couple of people a document
which is the estimated cost of a new 18
bed Juvenile Justice Facility treatment
facility whatever we're calling it
um so I can tell you how much it would
cost to build a
a 12 to 18 bed facility which means an
18 bed facility and and how much that
would cost to build all in which is
about 21 let's call it 21.5 million I
can also tell you what's it cost to get
us to bidable documents that is to say
if we hired and we're on the verge of we
would be on the verge of hiring an
architecture an engineering firm to do
the design work under the typical State
process what would it cost to to do that
and design contingency and and
commissioning fees Etc and it would be
just under two million dollars so so
that number we came up with 1.7 to 1.8
million
um
so let me put it this way let me let me
break this up into bite-sized pieces if
I can
if today we are deciding to build an
18-bed facility
which is 12 because if you build a 12
bed facility that can accommodate 18
it's from a construction standpoint not
programming it's an 18 bed facility if
today we build an 18 bed facility and we
start the Contracting process of getting
a firm getting to GNC in the next few
meetings
um it would be from about now until we
until we bid about a year
and you know not 365 days but about a
year
um and then the construction phase of
that would be another
um let's call it a year and a half if
you ask me for a ballpark
um I think Ted would say we would
anticipate a building if we got started
more or less today uh to be ready to
transfer to HHS for
occupancy or whatever roughly September
30th 2025.
um that's a that's a that's a very good
ballpark number I mean obviously
that that's that sounds like a
consistent number that you've been
sharing with people before and and in
the sb1 I think Senator Carson added a
little Kentucky windage to that and made
it November of of 25 is is that your
understanding yeah I uh never opposed A
little bit of Kentucky windage added to
construction is unpredictable so yes and
in the sb1 they also included the
governor could uh go for an additional
year to 2026 I believe I'm sure I've
read the final draft of that bill as it
passed yeah so so I'm happy that our
timelines are lining up and I'm happy
that you've said that uh you think the
the work that's stipulated in Amendment
zero three one one of the walner
amendment
um that that work for site evaluation
architectural consultation development
and design options for the replacement
facility that that that that that could
be that a two million dollar estimate is
a good estimate it may be a little high
so so wouldn't we
assuming it is a little high wouldn't we
want to just put another sentence in
there to say that any money left over
can be contributed towards con
construction should we go forward
or or not
well if if it's less than two million
what do we do with the change
it goes back into the general
funds we'd laugh let me let me just get
if I can I want I want Ted to give you
just a couple seconds on what this
estimate does entail and doesn't entail
in case there's some stuff you want done
that we're not complete can you spell
your last name k-u-p-p-e-r
first name is Theodore
um so I'm a professional engineer
employed by the state working for the
division of Public Works
and
um we're we're right now on the verge of
approving and negotiate a contract with
a consultant
and that contract
would be to evaluate potentially three
sites and the evaluation would simply be
to select the site that the design would
be completed for
um
so we're looking at evaluating three
sites and then proceeding into the
design phase of the project which
Charlie mentioned would be about 11
months
at the end of that design phase and an
expenditure of about 1.8 million dollars
we would have in our hands a full set of
construction documents and
specifications that we would be ready to
bid
if we had an appropriation that would
fund the construction of the facility
well well that's a lot there's some
breaking news in there I think for some
of us that that you all are ready to go
ahead and let a contract to begin the
design work I think there's a good news
aspect to that the the other side of it
is
um
what what design assumptions will go
into that there's a lot of language in
sb1 and there was in the committee a
conference about the things that we
wanted to do have you have you decided
that you would issue those as the design
assumptions to help bound or scope the
project
um I'm not sure that I know exactly
what's in sb1 but I can outline for you
very basically what the scope of the
work for them would be well please do
um it would be a 12 bed facility that
would surge to 18 which is Charlie just
mentioned please please don't use the
word search
it's it's an inside thing don't use the
word search but what we have is a
maximum capacity of 18. a maximum
capacity of 18 Beds which as Charlie
mentioned
um is uh from our perspective an 18 bed
facility
uh we we're not quite sure how all of
those 18 beds would be used
um and that's something that in the
design process will determine
um you know there's as uh Joe mentioned
there is a
combination of uh males and females in
the facility uh there might be a reason
to isolate some of those populations
because they're sick or because perhaps
they're violent but all of that will be
determined
um you know when when we get through the
design how those 18 beds will be used
and how they'll be segregated
um so it would be the design of a core
facility
that would manage the 18 beds of about
5620 square feet
there'd be housing that would represent
7640 square feet
there'd be a recreational component to
the facility that would represent 3 500
square feet
there'd be maintenance portions of the
facility in order to maintain the
facility about a thousand square feet
and then mechanical electrical
circulation security walls the grossing
Factor if you will for any building
is about 8
335 square feet for a grand total of 25
140 square feet
um we're indicating to the consultant
we'd like them to use 25 000 square feet
for this facility
and because you're reading off of
something there's something you could
provide to the community this is the
document that Mr Arlington uh said that
he would provide okay and I'm going to
say something extreme and over simple to
give you a chance to correct it
um
what I think I heard you say is that
within available funds already within
the department you have about 1.8
million dollars to fund this design work
this is what I think I heard and that
you already have adequate design
criteria to to begin the analysis and
and if that's the case that
shifts what Our obligation is on what we
need to get out into into law so I want
to hear that very carefully that do you
already have the money to do this or do
you need this two million dollars that's
in the okay I believe there is
um there's no money appropriated yet for
this we're proceeding
um with the idea that money would be
appropriated
and uh and the task that was assigned to
us to develop these documents was how
much for an all-in 18 bed facility
What's the total price and of that total
price we've estimated that we're going
to require about 1.8 million dollars to
begin the design and Analysis uh thank
you for that do you think there's any
additional costs associated with sort of
this two-step process or maybe it's a
it's more effective and efficient but
but this would put us on a path of a
two-step process of going and doing the
design and Analysis and getting all the
documentation ready
full stop
second phase would be the construction
phase where we would issue another
contract to go build the thing
okay is that is is there a two-step
process implied and what you're thinking
you're going to do and and and what does
the two-step process do in terms of
which which is better good government
I think I understand your question
um we see it more like a pause rather
than a full stop so what we're
anticipating is that
um we might receive an appropriation of
1.8 million dollars that would begin the
design process
and in or about the time that we're
ready to bid the project so that 1.8
million has been expended and we're in
possession of the construction documents
that were ready to bid
um prior to that or on or about that
time there would be another
appropriation that would fund the
construction and we'd be able to roll
right into the bid to the bidding
process
now in our 1.8 million dollar estimate
we've provided a a very small
contingency
that he anticipates a delay in the
funding of the construction
appropriation
and that contingency would allow the
architectural firm that's working on
this design to go back and review the
design to make sure that when
construction money is appropriated that
all the current codes that we would bid
the project under would be met
so um
we see it more like a pause and even if
there is a hard stop and a small delay
before we proceed
um
we see that perhaps there might be some
advantage to this approach
the construction Market out there right
now is very volatile and very
unpredictable and the pricing associated
with that on our projects that we're
bidding currently are very uh difficult
to anticipate
going through a full design which would
include a cost estimate based on current
construction environment
um
would alert us to what we believe the
cost of that facility would be at that
time right before we go out to bid but
having said that we're anticipating that
the 21 point
five as Mr Arling house had summarized
it
um is adequate to build this facility of
18 beds can I can I pause here
I understand part of your question would
be the notion of
two contracts versus one like design
build versus we we anticipate an
engineering contract and then a
Construction contract a year later and I
think you're asking about that yes
that's it I I I heard Ted answer that
you can you can I I just wanted to say
that this is actually typical of large
projects that we do that there's a
design contract separate and it is it is
uh on occasion we do design build where
it's one contract right they design and
build it together it's typically much
smaller projects and the bigger projects
so this is consistent with the
traditional State process so so this
this is uh this is great I I um as I'm
looking at sb1 and I'm jumping around a
little bit on you but this is also going
to show up in an amendment here today I
think is
um
I think sb1 anticipates a design build
concept are you familiar with sb1 enough
to validate that there they they're
looking design build and what we're
hearing today is the the notion of a
design and then a separate build
contract
I believe we changed that language in
sb1 do you have the final amended
version that went through well it shows
the the sum of 15 million for a fiscal
year
appropriated for the design and
construction of the new facility as
described in two so they it literally
says design and construction I think the
our interpretation of language like that
would be that the well the appropriation
think of that like a capital budget
appropriation where that's typically how
the capital budget is appropriated
here's 15 million dollars to accomplish
this and you and the two separate
contracts both come out of that one
appropriation and that that's my read of
that where they're not it doesn't
specify you must do the design build
process you can't do design bid build
okay okay thank you for educating me on
that
um and then I I think one of my fears uh
is that uh nsb1 due to the timing issue
they they say that the governor shall
first use any available discretionary
funds appropriated in the American
Rescue plan Act of 2021 and I'm I'm just
curious if this approach of doing the
design and the methodical way and then
the the build part if that's going to
cause us to lose access to the arpa
money and and that is is that a question
you can address Mr Arlington what do you
what do you think can we can we write
this in a way where you so you could in
the on the arpa money our timeline for
finishing the work meets with when you
must finish the arpa work by
um and I think the the arpa funds would
have to be committed by and I I don't
claim to have any clue as to whether
legislative leaders are or the governor
wants to use arpa funds or not but
um you could do it in addition to that
the approach that we're describing
doesn't
presuppose that you must do it as two
separate Appropriations you could do it
as one appropriation
all right and and I I think I think we
agreed though that the 15 million that's
in sb1 is too low and and I just want to
understand your 21.6 estimate and the
1.8 estimate is that is is that is a
21.6 estimate inclusive of the 1.8 it is
okay so it's not an additive it's not
2.16 plus 1.8 okay all right uh Mr
ribson you had a comment I just yeah I
just want to add a couple things um and
certainly you can you can list a
testimony yourself but the governor's
budget director did come before Senate
Finance to testify on these issues and
said that there was 15 million dollars
in arpa reserved for this purpose
um that the it was anticipated that the
timeline that has been discussed the
funds would be available to to support
the construction that 50 million would
be available to support the construction
design in that timeline and then I would
just want to comment that if if it was a
two-step appropriation that required
legislative action in the middle I would
be concerned that you wouldn't be able
to hit that timeline right if there was
something if there was you know some
other bill that had to happen or some
other thing that had to happen in the
middle that would be another
process that would slow down the the
ability to reach that arpa deadline so
so representative Weiler
thank you Mr chair I have a question
while we have Mr cupper here
has there been an analysis thinking long
terms when this
Youth Center is empty
there's been an analysis of what it
could be used for say a secure
psychiatric unit or drug treatment
facility have those
things been looked at because obviously
with the construction costs we're
talking that building was built for 20
million now here we're coming out with
something much smaller for 20 million so
it would seem a waste to not try to
utilize a facility for something that
would be a project that's in the works
thank you
um I'll say this we we have not done any
evaluation of what the sununu center
could be used for
but we have determined that the two the
sununu center
um is not appropriate as a replacement
for this facility
but but we don't know what the sununu
center could be used for we haven't
looked at that
is it possible you could do that
analysis
I'm sure we could thank you
foreign
representative Wallner I I just was
looking for where to to address
representative Wilder's comment there I
think there's a section in here where uh
in sb1 and then maybe in this amendment
we have given to das some legislative
priorities on what to do with that
property and as the way I recall what's
in the legislation the bill
says that when we dispose of it that we
should try to be putting a high priority
on getting local uh tax relief to
Manchester into the state that that
that's what's in the amendment that we
can talk about later and maybe modify
but well I think it's a mistake to get
rid of a building that was designed to
be secure that we have other things to
do and look at the construction costs
from what it was 11 12 years ago
whenever it was built versus now it
would seem to be such a waste if we
don't make proper use of it or a state
facility thank you I would say that
representative Weiler that I I do
understand that and in our Capital
planning processes it is something we we
absolutely take into account
um it's not something that that we've
looked at directly and nobody's made any
decisions about the future use of that
property and you know I don't know
people are going to want to sell it or
whatnot but but whatever we would do
it's something where we're we routinely
look at every vacant building we have
and and whether it's
fixable or tear downable
thank you representative Waller did you
uh yes so I didn't know we were gonna
I'm whipping up to
Senate bill one I didn't know we were
talking about Senate bill one today so
we're in here I see the appropriation
for
15 million which is
going to be
the arpa money
where's the rest of the funding coming
from
I I think what I would say is that
um
so the I'm aware that the Senate has
passed the bill that has 15 million
dollars in it for this purpose and and
uh what I've been asked is uh for the
purpose has defined what would it cost
and I would tell you that that number is
um not 15. it's uh 21 and a half
thank you
and I have I have one other question
over the years I've always heard that
the federal government had given us the
money to build the original sununu
Center and that
we have to pay them back if we don't use
it for children it has to be a facility
I'm not even I'm not even clear what the
words are whether it's children who are
incarcerated or what it is
um what do we know about that and how
much is that costing to return the
building to the to turn funding to the
feds yeah I can answer that I actually
have good news this story has changed
since I think the last time Mr Ripple
has investigated it for for the
committee that reviewed this matter 18
months ago
um so uh There Are Rules around the
requirement to repay arpa funds um if
you stop using it for a youth related
purpose however they issued new guidance
in May of 2022 and they still require
you to go back to the feds to get
approval but they basically say that the
federal interest in a facility is 15
years or the end of the usable
life of the facility and that time frame
has now passed
because you said
repay arpa funds but I'm sorry
I meant to say voidance funds okay great
I was like the funding streams are just
mixing up I meant to say voidance funds
so you do anticipate that you won't have
to pay back that's what the new guidance
that came out in May of 2022 suggests
although the prior guidance does say you
have to go back to the feds once you've
decided what your course of action is
and get them to approve your plan but
according to the guidance that they
issued in May of 2022 their interest in
the property and in the repayment only
lasts for 15 years or the usable
lifespan of the property and we've
passed the 15 years at this point great
thank you yep
so you you raised a valid question about
are we talking about sb1 uh
no there's two amendments I have that I
haven't introduced yet because we're
still on your Amendment but the two
amendments I have have that language in
it so I I use the shorthand of sb1
because more people have read it and are
familiar with it than they are these
amendments that the ink is still wet
so
um all right so let's come back let's
loop back around to
um representative walners Amendment zero
three one one
and what what I think
would I think I picked up is that is
that uh
this amendment probably needs to have a
section on it Mr Ripple I'm kind of like
talking to you as we go through this if
we if we were to do another amendment
that
um
that we probably need to add a paragraph
So that we have operations money to get
through the end of this fiscal year
that uh as long as if if we if we're not
going to do sb1 and we're going to do
something with 49 it's going to have to
go back to the Senate
um so if we wanted to representative
Waller here to your point about the 15
million dollars is probably inadequate
and that we should put I I what I think
I'm hearing you say is that we ought to
put the right number in in there so that
there's some transparency right now it
says 15 million and although we want
them to prioritize arpa it may be that
we need to supplement that with some
additional funding that I I I that's
what I think where you're going with
that no I just I just wanted I all I
wanted to do was
no if in well we're not supposed to talk
about it but Senate Bill won if there
was some place in that bill where there
was the additional funding to get it up
to the 21. and there is not so when we
get to my Amendment you'll see it and
then it's a lift from sb1 anyway so
um okay so just as a as a marker we'll
talk about whether or not extra funds
are needed
and then
um I I and although the department has a
proposal ready to go is there any
requirement or necessity or is it's just
better practice if we passed
some design criteria to you so that
there's backup for your proposal or or
is that just a moot action at this point
traditionally to do design of any
building what we would do is consult
with the using agency about the
appropriate design and to the extent
that you're you and they are comfortable
that that you're both on the same page
there's no need for it I've got no
pushback on the Design Concepts I've
gotten pushback on the capacity
so our capacity we would we would take
lead from you on and then and if there's
no language we would then consult with
with Joe and his team about about
specifics of Design Within the
appropriated money so so for purposes of
discussion and thinking I I think the
the sort of the new new thing for you
all is that
um I think we need to think in terms of
uh at least two probably just two
Alternatives independent of which of the
three sites it goes on but just on the
building wherever it goes that in one
option the building should be for a
smaller capacity say six to eight uh
with the anticipation that should the
need arise we could readily build
additional capability adjacent to that
building so there would need to be sort
of a plan to you know build a hallway
and to a a site that's not yet been
built but could be if we decided to the
second one is the one that you're
already all over the 12 to 18. so so the
introduction here today to A New Concept
is we might want to take a look at a
smaller design so that we understand the
cost differentials we would
I would ask that we could get back to
you with a different number than if the
if the design team is going to do a
couple of buildings and I understand
that there's some similarities so it's
not like doubling the cost or anything
but it's it's an additional an addition
to the scope of work if they do two
buildings not one so let me figure out
what that's going to cost and get back
to you with it right right the questions
representative hole thank you Mr chair I
guess when I'm hearing three potential
sites it's my assumption that does not
include redoing something either at the
current city new center location or
retrofitting the current sununu Center
is that a correct assumption
yeah I think that's sure the three
potential sites are the current site not
the current building so it's not
retrofitting the current building but
somewhere on the current campus
somewhere in Concord in proximity to New
Hampshire hospital so that you could
have shared services there or in
Hampstead and proximity to Hampstead
Hospital so you could have shared
services there
so
hearing the cost per child in these are
naive questions because I'm coming at
this
um kind of out of the blue
the cost to renovate might be less
can we at least look at that again and I
don't know whether you can do that
concurrently but to take a facility that
was significantly larger in size
right is there any way and I've never
walked through it I've actually never
been on the property so there this might
be completely impossible but is there a
way to take a look at that as one of the
options
I think it's something we can look at
although I don't know that the cost of
renovating a building that's not
currently up to standards is there are
dramatic savings from that I mean I
renovation is sometimes cheaper and in a
case like this though the the
you know the this we're not building an
office building and so if it's if it's
not substantial we would be essentially
replicating and then adding a demo cost
to it and so it's probably a push
I would still miss rips just one moment
uh we've already talked we have talked
about this option I don't know the
extent to which we have a historical
record or the depth on it but just so
you know when on your on your diagram uh
where it says that we attempted to
resolve this in the sununu replacement
committee we had five people and four
recommendations one of them was the
renovation of the existing site to
basically try to rescope it re-rebuild
it on the interior to make it nice and
um so so so the it's come up in
conversation before I don't know how
much homework it would take to go pull
any of that back out but so I'm sorry to
interrupt you I just wanted to get the
historical context yeah no that's that's
helpful and yeah I was going to say that
was that was thoroughly examined during
the committee about 18 months ago that
that was examining kind of what to do
next the other the other piece of this
is well one you know sb1 one and HP 120
and the legislation from last year all
kind of anticipated really moving this
into a more of a therapeutic type
setting which the current design is and
I understand what you're saying is
really kind of refashioning it in a way
that would kind of move into more of a
therapeutic space the other thing that's
really key about this if you're talking
it from from an economic perspective is
um
is the long-term operational costs I
think are are really key when you're
trying to balance the the cost of this
it's not just the cost of renovation
versus the cost of a new build but it's
also the savings year after year from a
co-located model one of the real
challenges of sysc has been that as the
census has declined which is I think a
great thing from a public policy and a
treatment of Youth perspective the
economies of scale have gotten to the
point that it's really really hard to
operate in a way that makes much sense
um and and by Able by being able to
co-locate to have some shared services
with another facility that does some
comparable
um work you're able to at least realize
somewhat better operational efficiencies
over time to reduce some of those
recurring costs that happen year after
year
who had a question
representative Waller you have another
question
no I think
um the question I was going to ask I
answered thank you okay so let's let's
do a time check
um we've got about
um five minutes until we hit 12 30.
what's Magic about 12 30. if we break at
12 30 that gives everyone 30 minutes to
go get lunch and Shake It Off and and
then we we reconvene as a division at 1
pm to start hitting some briefings
prepared by the department
uh we are not done here obviously we're
going to have to uh schedule additional
time based on the pace of what we've
done today it feels to me like we need
to find another three hour work session
at some point Mr Ripple if you could you
know begin to work on that
I I would like to go ahead and
foreshadow do you do you have one more
amendment that you you want to share
with us publicly or or not
no the other amendment was just a date
change
oh the real simple one yeah the real the
real story just the first paragraph yeah
no I thought so that was the simple one
could I ask Mr rip someone let me finish
this one point then so what I want to
let everyone know is I I have two
amendments that are incredibly uh close
to one another because it's uh
20203 h i I don't know if you all have a
copy of it or is uh zero one nine two
the essence of both of these would be to
take 49 very close to sb1 language and
there's some small nuances there were
some Advocates that came to me after
children and family law and and insisted
that uh some word Precision was needed
um and uh and so I deferred to their
judgment so these amendments are
extremely close to sb1
with a few semantic tweaks so so next
time we get to be together in the work
session I would like to pick up and be
able to to really start hitting these
the these amendments so that we can make
sure that whatever we do is
um is uh as thorough as it needs to be
go ahead Mr ripson I I wondered have you
done some
um estimates of what
the operational cost of the facility
will be and then my other question for
you and maybe you don't want to answer
it today but just get some information
for us for our our next time that we
need the other thing I was wondering is
sometimes I feel like we put the cart
before the horse because
um even you were saying that you
anticipate that the population
will go down and so we've been running
let's say at the maximum we've been
running 18.
mostly closer to 12
and here we are building a building for
the maximum
I I happen to have been one of the
people I was here right here when we
built the sununu center
and look what happened there we over
built
um and so I'm wondering is are you what
are you doing about thinking about
um as this population is going down are
we really needing to build at 18 and how
much could we
possibly save by not building at 18.
so I I have a few thoughts on that one
on the operational costs and I have some
information that I imagine
representative Edwards was alluding to
that I'll be that I'll share when we
come back around potential cost savings
largely largely through the ability to
co-locate and share Services through
with another facility is where much most
of those savings come from
um and uh and I'll go into more detail
about that so I do have some information
about that in terms of the size and
savings right I think
um so obviously our colleagues here
could talk about in terms of building a
building for six beds versus 18 beds
right but in terms of building a
building for six beds versus 18 beds we
saw a little taste of this last year
through two fiscal notes right we had a
fiscal note for an 18 bed facility and a
fiscal note for a six bed facility and
the difference was about two million
dollars between building those two it
wasn't that big because the core of
those two facilities was pretty
comparable the other thing that I would
say is
um one right the data nationally shows
us that we're already pretty low
two what we're looking to build here is
not the same as an sysc and I know
that's something that I hear people keep
saying this is just a mini sysc it's not
what we're looking to build here is a
facility that really is designed to be a
treatment facility and a trauma-informed
facility and that if the day comes and I
hope it does that we that this building
is too big it would be appropriate to
transition into a therapeutic program it
would be appropriate to become a
psychiatric residential treatment
facility and that's one of the things
that when we went through the process of
interviewing Architects that that we
were thinking about that we want to be
able to design this building to be
something that could convert into a
treatment program in the future if we do
get to that day where it turns out that
we don't need 18 beds anymore I don't
know that we will get to that day but if
we do I'll be happy and if we do we can
use this for a better purpose one of the
big problems with sysc and I hear
chairman Weiler you know is
it's hard to find another good purpose
for it because it was built for a
correctional purpose and it's actually
not really you know when we tried to put
a treatment program in there Proprietors
didn't want to go in it that's one of
the reasons why it was why it didn't
work right providers didn't want to use
that space for a treatment purpose
because it feels Correctional it feels
heavy no matter how much we try to dress
it up
um and uh that's not what this will be
and that's not what this will look like
this is going to look like something
that could be approved by a joint
committee uh you know a Jayco approval
for a hospital if it was to be used for
that purpose in the future because I
think we need to anticipate that maybe
we do become the state that that is able
to get our numbers down so low that we
don't need 18 beds anymore and I also
want to say you know 18 beds is not
because I anticipate us having 18 kids I
regularly our census is on average 12.
and I think our average will probably
get down to 10 probably single digits in
the next five years but sometimes we
have more kids and we often need to
separate kids you know and if you have
three units and you only have one girl
and she's taking up five beds because
you have one girl in a five bed unit
then you don't have a whole lot of beds
for the rest of the boys right so it's
it's about flexibility more than it is
about the number of beds so you know all
that's to say is you know I have given
thought to that and I think you know the
way that we think about that is being a
little bit more thoughtful about next
usage in our in our design today
no that that I figured you I figured you
had some anticipated costs that you
would be bringing to us I do know that
there are
our former chairman
um Mr Kirk is in the audience and he
spent
years working on this and I
I know he's been sitting out there all
day I wondered if you would maybe let
him give some thoughts he spent many
years on this subject thank you for the
suggestion I I think I was channeling
you because as I was looking in the
audience I see our speakers here I see
The Honorable Neil Kirk I see other
people and uh you know
Mr Mr Kirk or do you do you have an
interest in coming and speaking of the
committee about your perspective and and
your view of the history your your we're
blind signing you a little bit that you
and I talked a tiny bit yesterday
would you like to talk with us
just just uh Mr arlinghaus before you
guys go just if we can have your
documents with your numbers on it okay
outstanding and thank you are you going
to stay or go
okay thanks uh thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee it's always a
pleasure to be here and an opportunity
to give you a perhaps a different
perspective
um
I started working on this seriously in
2016 and we had hopes that this problem
would be resolved many years ago
for a whole variety of reasons that
hasn't happened
um
let me give you my perspective and I can
justify it later if you want but just as
an overall thing
um
there's a great deal of contention
between the house and the Senators to
the size of this facility the Senate
wants 18 the house wants 60 wants six it
was a compromise at 12 that failed in
conference committee for a variety of
reasons the senates now come back with
18 the same proposal they had last time
and there seems to be a great deal of
pressure to on on this committee and the
house to get this through immediately
the problem is that the situation is
changing
and
Senate Bill 1 and House Bill 120 are
designed to deal with a static situation
not a changing situation
the situation is changing because this
house and the Senate have changed the
rules as to who as to which children go
to the sununu center or its replacement
as you saw from Mr ribson's chart those
numbers drop precipitously if the house
version of what was at one point House
Bill 254 had been adopted
that would go those numbers would go
down even faster because it would only
allow the most severe children
most violent children to go to the
sununa center
so at the end of the day it seems to me
that you folks are faced with a
situation now where you're trying to
build a building
and deal with a situation based on last
year's numbers
and the situation is evolving so that
next year's numbers will be different
why would we want to build a building as
we've done in the past as representative
Wallner suggested
the sununa center was built to
accommodate 144 it never had that
population and now it has what 18 to 12
or 6 according to Mr ribsum
the situation is changing as a result of
the changes this house has made and if
some future if some other changes are
made these numbers will go down further
so my suggestion is that this committee
paused the process
representative walner's amendment is a
start to do that let's start planning
for something but not actually do it
till we see the numbers next year the
numbers are going to be different
probably lower the year after the
numbers are going to still be lower
so we what we don't want to do is to
create a third sununu Center we have the
first one YDC and that was a disaster in
terms of
accusations of inappropriate behavior by
staff we know we've said a hundred
million dollars aside for the problems
with the sununu center itself and staff
do we really want to create a third
sununu Center we all know what the
definition of insanity is
doing the same thing again and again and
expecting a different result
I would slow down the process at this
point I would not go with Senate bill
one I would not go with House Bill
120 I would slow down the process start
some design work
but not actually make a commitment as to
the size until in the future we see what
the numbers might be
um
I'd hate for us to make
uh to repeat history and make the same
mistake that we've made twice
and that's what Senate bill I believe
what Senate bill and one and House Bill
120 do so
I'd be pleased to answer questions but
my advice is to to slow this down and
not at this time make the ultimate
decision which is what those two bills I
mentioned does
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
that I I just um I I want to read just a
small snippet of of what is an sb1
relative to their capacity uh they they
said that they wanted to have a maximum
physical capacity of 18 with an
operational plan to support 12. and so
the extra six beds there are intended to
be for Flex use due to the things that
Mr ribson has talked about I don't I
don't think any of us are wanting to
have 18 in there on a permanent basis
that's
that's just my interpretation of that
and then and then have you have you ever
talked to Representative Bob Lin about
254 and his reservations about uh the
viability of of those changes to the
juvenile law yes representative Lynn has
a much more expansive view of the kinds
of children who should go to sununu then
I think the legislature has historically
and in several builds there was to deal
with the situation he raised because his
concern was legitimate there was a
position a provision for what's called a
Judicial override
so that despite the statute if the if a
judge felt that a particular child who
didn't meet the criteria to go to the
sununu center would nonetheless be
appropriate there then the judge could
place the student that that child in the
replacement facility
um I don't know that that satisfies uh
representative Lynn completely but it
certainly would deal with the uh odd
case that comes up where a juvenile is
extremely violent but yet has not done
one of the acts that would require
detention or commitment to sununu yeah
yes sir and so are you aware of any
bills that we may have in the house that
would do what 254 was going to do
because we didn't pass 254 the
provisions of 254 that were in in the
committee a conference that didn't pass
and there are no 254 like Precision
positions in sb1 so so I don't know that
we have any legislative direction to
implement the changes that were hoped to
reduce the population are am I missing
one I don't know of any Bills currently
filed but this committee can certainly
produce an amendment to do that and Tack
it on to
um house bill Senate bill one or tack it
on to more appropriately I think to
perhaps to house spill 49 although I'm
concerned my thought was that 49 would
be a stop Gap you would amend 49 the way
representative Wallner is suggesting for
example plus the money that you need if
in fact you need it
based on what Mr Ripple said you would
put that into this bill and you would
get the process going without making a
direct commitment then you'd retain one
as a child and family law has retained
120. and work on and work on those over
the next biennium putting money in the
budget this year
for the next two years where these
children in under any circumstances are
still going to be at the sununu center
unless you decided to have them go
elsewhere on a per diem basis
so I was hoping to see
House Bill 49 to go forward as an
interim step
and give the committee either through
the budget process which would give you
another three months to work on this or
through some bills in the next session
an opportunity to make the longer term
commitment when facts became clearer
as and as I say you certainly could
amend this bill to put in some of House
Bill 54 if you needed to which would of
course speed the process to eliminating
or decreasing the population in the
short term and that would save the state
a considerable amount of money which has
been one of the things that I've been
concerned about we've been spending 13
million dollars a year for a long time
at the sununu center I understand that
this new facility would cost about 9
million or so a year on the 12 to 18 bed
depending on what the numbers are which
is some somewhat of a saving but there's
a considerable saving to be made if for
example we were to put these children
into facilities either in the private
sector or in other states on a per diem
basis
um it's it's interesting to note that um
if there are
let's see six children in in in this
facility on average we're spending a
million and a half a year
um if there are at nine million a year
on the operating costs
um if there are more children the per
child cost goes down but I've always
been concerned Mr chairman about the
operating cost of the facility because
that's what that's what hits the budget
the one-time expense for the for the
construction whether it's 15 million or
20 million or something like that
in the long run is a relatively small
operating cost if you look at this from
a business perspective if this building
has a life of 50 years and it's a 25
million dollar building it's costing you
what half a million a year
um to
depreciate the building and add that to
your quote operating costs
but it whatever this committee can do to
reduce the operating costs benefits the
taxpayers of New Hampshire
and building a larger facility with a
higher operating cost to me is not in
the best interest of taxpayers and as an
ex-finance guy that's one of the things
that really concerns me will you will
you take another question sure okay so
let's let's say we built for X whatever
X is and
although we have plans and and
approaches to try to reduce the number
from y to X let's say in the future that
doesn't happen for whatever reason what
what would be the backup plan to deal
with any number that needed to be taken
care of above X would you what would you
do with uh
a census larger than what the facility
design can accommodate
um that's a problem that would occur
whether the facility is 12 beds to 18
beds or six beds to eight beds yes sir
what do you do if you have a surgeon
excuse me for using that dirty word what
would happen if you had a surge in
population and the answer is you would
do the same thing that Vermont and some
other states have done Vermont put many
of their children out into New Hampshire
and we took care of them New Hampshire
can place some of its children in
Massachusetts state facilities or Maine
State facilities although Maine is
having a problem at that moment at the
moment there are also private sector
facilities that can take these children
if we wanted to either on a permanent or
short-term basis so I think there are
ways that regardless of the size of the
facility we could place children who for
a short period of time exceeded the
capacity of the facility whether it's
six beds 12 beds or 18 beds
that's a good question Mr chairman but I
think there is a reasonable answer for
that regardless of facility size right
and would you believe that after like 20
to 30 hours of hearings on this subject
you're the first person that has ever
answered the question or been asked the
question I think of what do we do if we
have an uh the rare instance of
exceeding the capacity of our building
what's what's what's the worst case
fallback plan and and and so I think
we're going to need to have one that
that needs to be part of what our
considerations are and whether that's
and do we enter into a relationship to
send them out of state to another
facility or or what do we do in state so
I I don't think we have an answer but I
appreciate you you know opening us up
with a an idea thank you Mr chairman you
might consider checking with the
Department because there are probably
occasions in the past when for a variety
of reasons some of our children have had
have been placed elsewhere other than in
sununu you might want to inquire about
that to see what options the department
currently has available to deal with
these situations yes sir thank you so
much are there are other questions for
representative honorable Kirk no
well okay well thank you sir appreciate
it thank you Mr Speaker you're always
welcome it feels like it's your room in
some way so thank you sir all right
um okay so uh last time we did a time
check we were getting close to 12 30.
we're at 12
46. so as I look at what we're going to
do this afternoon I'm going to go ahead
and
if there are no objections from the
committee put us into recess
I think I have to kick back off at one
o'clock in order to comply with a
calendar
I will come back at one o'clock and I
will open the hearing and then I will
recess the hearing so that you all can
come back at say 1 20 and then you've
got you still have about 30 minutes to
stretch your legs and try to get
something to eat so so that's that's my
game plan will will officially open
again at one but I'll just put that into
recess till 1 20.
no no complaints all right okay so Mr
Ripple if you could help me with this
we're we're at recess until one
um I think that's fine for now I think
exactly the plan that you just said is
what you should do come back in at one
and recess until 1 20. that's that's
what I want to do I just don't know what
sign gets put up on the YouTube oh
um I'm not sure whoever is monitoring
this from gcts will put something up
okay all right if somebody dials in at
105 I want them to know that they're not
alone I think it'll just say the
committee is in recess and we'll resume
shortly I don't think they'll have an
exact time all right okay thank you
we're we are now in recess
mm-hmm
foreign
thank you
all right uh it being one o'clock uh I
will uh open the work session in for
division three
but we will immediately go into recess
until about 1 20.
second one for recess
thank you
yeah
foreign
thank you
okay
um it's uh 124 I think uh and I'm going
to call us out of recess and we're going
to start off this session by asking uh
for a presentation from the Department
no no dollars to be discussed but we
want to hear about the mobile Behavioral
Health and the New Hampshire hospital
let's see
we're okay so representative Mooney is
checking to see if we're live on uh
YouTube
and I don't know what the rule is this
year whether we can start okay
okay all right
one more one more moment and you'll be
live
and okay thank you
okay so uh introduce yourself uh
representative holzar clerk today
the name and title and
good afternoon Mr
on your handout so you should be able to
see the spelling and I am the director
of the division for Behavioral Health
and good afternoon I'm Julianne carbon
I'm going to ask you to get the
microphone really really close for two
reasons one I'm deaf I have a hearing
problem and then we're broadcasting so I
don't know what the audio quality is
going out
okay good afternoon is that better
that's better
my name is Julianne carbon I'm the
director for the Bureau of Mental Health
Services
so we're going to go through and address
the first part of this block that you
have and then New Hampshire hospital
will be presenting as well so
thank you for inviting us to talk about
something that we really are proud of
and proud of our providers in able in
their ability to stand up this program
before you you should have our
presentation and then you should have a
series of other documents that include
the
um
10-year plan uh key accomplishments and
that's a front and back I believe you'll
you'll find that we have the New
Hampshire rapid response with an
explanation along with our statistics
from the calendar year from
2022 you have the
um a side-by-side of explanation of the
differences and the similarities between
988 and New Hampshire rapid response
and you also should have a copy of our
10-year plan
so with that I'll kick us off
um we want to ground this because we
know that we'll be coming before you to
discuss a number of our programs today
we're only focused on New Hampshire
rapid response in our crisis system but
there'll be other programs that we'll be
talking about as we enter into the
budget cycle so all of this is driven in
our guiding Stars so to speak is these
plans that have been created with
myriads of stakeholders including
legislators and supported by the
governor and the legislature so on the
second page you'll find that list we
have the 10-year plan which we made
available to you we have the children's
system of care which is actually RSA 135
F and was created as part of Senate bill
2. I mean Senate bill 14
um we also have a strategic plan from
the governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs as well as a suicide
prevention strategic plan which was
developed under the auspices of our
Suicide Prevention Council
and so then you can see what our vision
statement is as we move forward and work
to fulfill the vision of all of these
plans with keeping all of them in mind
and driving our work
so I'm going to tell you I'm I just want
to make sure I'm looking at the right
sheet of paper sure I started looking at
the the behavioral health that's stapled
it's got multiple slides is that what
we're on yes that's what we're on okay
so that's actually the one that has
um the overview okay and with our names
on it February 3rd and for those of you
who are looking for this online it's in
the division three area under the LBA
all of our documents should be posted I
think these are all posted right
yep okay okay I'm I'm getting back in
sync with you what what page are you on
now so now oh
three
this is our coordinated Continuum of
Care again today we're talking about the
right hand side which is our crisis and
inpatient services but we wanted to also
share this with you so that you see our
full Continuum of Care and this actually
carries across not just for mental
health services but also for substance
misuse services and uh for our other
programs in fact you might be able to
apply this across many of our programs
across the department not just within
the division for Behavioral Health so we
have Community Education we have
prevention and early intervention
Outpatient Treatment
step up and step down which is really
references to Transitions in care and
then again the crisis in inpatient
Services which we're here to talk about
today
so with that I'll have Julianne continue
so the next slide slide four just shows
a more detailed overview of our crisis
system
starting with our crisis contact center
so it goes from at least least most
community-based to inpatient beds so we
have the full Continuum crisis services
including mobile response teams around
the state we have peer operated programs
throughout the state for Step Up step
down as well as rapid respite services
we have crisis residential in three
regions of the state that are available
Statewide crisis Apartments then of
course we have our Hospital Systems
State operated inpatient beds as well as
other community-based inpatient beds
can I say something here
um okay just just just to make sure you
you know
why you were invited as a special topic
on mobile Behavioral Health
um and everything you're doing is great
I'm not I don't want to throw you off of
what you intended to say but I I just
want to want you to know that from a
financial perspective one of the things
that has
bothered me a little bit just because
that's the way I am is
um we have in different budgets and
different sections it seems like we have
multiple areas in which these mobile
response teams this second bullet down
the mobile crisis response teams it felt
to me like there were six total units
and they were spread over four different
areas and uh and there weren't any
common metrics for all six of them and
and so because these are valuable
important critical assets in the
entirety of our Continuum I I wanted to
drill down and really understand
how many of these do we have how many of
them are really Vans you know what kind
of stuff goes into a typical van you
know how many calls do they go on I I
really wanted to understand
operationally what it how these are are
are are are viewed within the department
and managed so Mr chair
um we're getting there if you flip to
your next Slide the rest of our
presentation is all about the mobile
teams that you're referencing yeah I
fell for this yesterday I I did actually
look ahead are coming and I'm not seeing
the slides I was anticipating in my head
but it's okay you just stay the course
you're doing great
and and we know that there are new
members of this committee so we know
that um your Keen focus on this but we
wanted to give at least some background
on context for what we do especially
with New Hampshire hospital coming
um right behind us because our whole
point of our community-based services is
to ensure that people do not need to get
to the level of the acute care we want
to intervene sooner and so there are
other programs other than mobile
response so we just wanted to embed it
in that so I apologize if we didn't say
that up front no apology necessary
you're doing great I'm just letting you
know that by the end of the budget cycle
I want to have a crystal clear view of
of what a unit of mobile response crisis
team looks like because I understand
that there are different iterations or
versions of them you know I I I just I
want to get into the details
representative pilersky thank you so
much I just for my own benefit a little
definition work I hear things often
about peer support I see peer operated
beds and peer respite can you just give
me a quick definition of what that
actually means thanks
yes so for the context of of these
Services here what we mean by peer is an
individual who identifies as having a
lived experience or personal experience
with a mental health condition who is
you know living in recovery and gone
through a specific training curriculum
to be a certified peer
so it's as opposed to clinicians
so um
I just need to interject it's a sphere
warning or weather warning kind of thing
the temperatures are dropping rapidly if
we have anyone who's parked over at the
stores a parking garage you're invited
at any point to go move your car while
there's still some warmth in the air and
you can relocate your car into the lob
parking lot there's some spaces on the
upper part of that and they're yellow
bags around the yellow bee that you can
park in those spots without a ticket
it's no trick you can actually do it so
um so that's your severe weather update
it's going to get very very cold sorry
to interrupt you so um Mr chair I just
wanted to say we hope that you walk out
with that information today and not have
to wait through till March to find out
that information so that's what our hope
is today to share this information find
out what additional information you want
and bring that back in a rapid manner
okay okay so the New Hampshire rapid
response is is
um our comprehensive crisis response
system community-based crisis response
system it's comprised of a 24 7
centralized contact center and so by
contact we mean it's accessible via
phone text and chat so we have one phone
number that is available Statewide so
folks call into the
access point and the majority of the
time their needs are met over the phone
or through the access point when so as a
member of the public should I just know
that number like I know 911
you would love it if you could schedule
it into your phone absolutely so what is
the phone number
so you can find that in some of the
materials that we handed out
so in both of those pieces of
information including the national 988
suicide and Crisis Line information it
shows that number so the the boxes one
oh okay so it's
833-710-6477 you got it so that's longer
than 9-1-1
it is how how are we going to make sure
that the public knows that remembers it
can use it because because I think this
is a it qualifies as a number but I
don't know if it qualifies as a easy to
access
are all the good numbers taken
two one one
so um
and out here that talks about 988 so 988
is the national
um crisis and suicide Lifeline that has
always been exist in existence but um it
did it used to be a 10 digit number and
it was simplified to an easy to remember
988 so that is a number that's available
to folks here in New Hampshire headrest
and Beacon Health are the vendors here
in New Hampshire that will answer those
calls the only caveat is that at high
volume times if the teams employed by
those agencies are not able to answer
the phone it rolls over to the National
backup
and so we can't guarantee that every
time someone calls 988 They will receive
a new hampshire-based call center that
has the capability of deploying our
mobile response teams or scheduling
follow-up appointments so while we are
trying to work with our national
Partners to figure out how to embed
those modalities nationally we are still
referring folks to that 10 digit number
we are working with a public relations
firm to try and do some more targeted
community-based Outreach and education
about the availability of New Hampshire
rapid response we wanted to make sure we
had some of those operations more fully
functional before doing a more broad
Outreach to the general public thank you
and through our efforts in standing up
9A Dade and having the New Hampshire
aspect of that we have brought together
2-1-1 and 9-1-1 so there are protocols
and policies in place so that if someone
calls the wrong number so to speak that
there will be follow-up action to get
them to the right the right number
remember me what 2-1-1 does so 211 is a
information and referral line I should
give it a plug today because it is a
place where people for example if you
need a warm place to go if you need a
warming station there being
advertised as the place to call so they
do a variety of services they're how you
access the doorway system in New
Hampshire they provide information about
housing it's it's quite broad what they
provide for information and referral
that's great thank you
so when someone reaches out to the
access point and it's determined that
they they need a higher level of support
the access point is able to deploy our
mobile response teams they have
Technology Solutions that's able to
identify the closest available team
within a one hour radius so a team of
two specialty trained responders will go
and meet someone in the community of you
know of their choice
and so that's the way our mobile
response system is set up we do have
some bullet points on slide eight but
what I can say is that
it is designed can you take a question I
don't I don't know representative Hull
do you have a question I do so on on the
mobile response teams are these
contracted services are these Direct
Services internal
so these are contracted Services through
our 10 Community Mental Health Centers
and uh to
um
Mr chair your question earlier there are
ten so we have 10 committee Mental
Health Centers each one has a team
and that's an update right wasn't it six
just two years ago no we
oh pardon me
so we've had a mobile crisis as part of
our community mental health agreement
which is the Amanda D settlement we had
the requirement that we contract
um in stand-up services in the three
major cities Nashua Manchester and
Concord so those have been in place for
a number of years and then with support
from the governor and the legislature
through the budget process we were able
to stand up the additional crisis teams
and that also was supported through the
system of care funding so so it's always
been 10. uh so it was always three and
everyone said well what about me and
through some excellent advocacy work
um we were able to see this become
Statewide and when we say 10 centers we
also know that there may be a sender
that has
a bigger need and may have a couple
things going on at this same time a
couple of deployments so it truly is
Statewide where they're able to deploy
another mobile team that's nearby that's
in a nearby region
and I want to address the issue of
whether there are Vans or not a couple
of the Centers do have Vans but they're
not always van so as you can imagine
with two people on call they're not
going to necessarily come together get
in a van and then deploy it really
depends on the region and it depends on
what the need is and where they'll be
going
okay before you get going I think
representative erf has a question just a
quick question in relation to what you
just said so essentially these are the
people that show up it's not like
equipment showing up with them so these
they've been driving their cars and be
there to help the person that they're
interacting with yeah that's that's the
idea and there are a lot of questions
about whether law enforcement deploys
with them again it's based on the
circumstances and who is making the call
whether it's a school it could be a
school and um they're responding to a
school it could be at a police station
where they're asking rather than have a
higher level intervention that they have
this team come this trained team come
and um and meet with them so yeah
and so so you because you mentioned that
sometimes they may need to deploy with
police support
do we have any experiences where one of
these teams has been launched and
they've ended up in the middle of a
domestic violence dispute of some kind
or I'm just you just got me worried
about the safety aspect for the team
that goes to somebody's home
information at the moment but nationally
what what is seen is less than two
percent of mobile deployments
require police presence so most of the
time when a mobile team is going out
there have been safety assessments on
the phone with the access point when the
mobile team is enroute they call and
make contact with the individual to
again get more detail more information
and do additional safety assessments and
and so it very rarely
escalates to that level
but it certainly does include law
enforcement when it's necessary
if we had anyone hurt
going on a deployment like that
um not to my knowledge
all right thank you
and I will say my reference to law
enforcement is sometimes we respond so
the mobile team responds at the request
of law enforcement which has identified
that there doesn't need to be uh uh um a
Justice involved situation that it's
just a matter of of needing to address
on the spot someone's uh concerns
so the next two slides just go on to
give a little bit of very high level
data we've had this system up and
running for a year now and so our
contact center has engaged with over 22
000 individuals Statewide approximately
17 of those are individuals under the
age of 18.
um and all you know from all regions of
the state
of those 22 000 contacts about 7 000
deployments have resulted so there has
been an assessed need to have someone
come out in person
um so that's about 31 which is a little
bit higher than the national average but
um
is is very much in line with the
national expectations of of what we
would see for mobile deployments and
again for our mobile deployments we see
a quite a significantly higher rate for
deployments for youth so about 42
percent of those mobile deployments were
for youth as opposed to 18 for adults
um and again as we said you know it uh
the teams are available Statewide
they're deploying Statewide part of the
advantage of this model is that as we
see Workforce challenges and Staffing
variations amongst the teams they're
able to support and cover when people
really need those deployments across
regions
so Mr chair you're going to have to
um forgive us for including dollars in
this next slide no I just don't want you
to get in trouble with Mr White that was
that was the promise
um
I I just I just there are dollars there
on slide six
or eight there's a question
oh go ahead
yeah thank you can you give me an idea
when a when a team responds to a a
situation of someone in crisis
um what often is the resolution or how
often does it involve taking that person
to a safe location and how often is it
you know talking them talking them to a
good place and reuniting them with a
safe person to make sure that they're
cared for
so that is data we are still in the
process of trying to about evaluate and
ensure it's it's valid as you can
imagine when we stand up any new program
it takes some time to ensure our data is
accurate
um so I don't have those numbers today
um
but that's something we can look into
sharing as soon as we have something
that that seems to reflective that our
data team feels like we can share and
and is appropriate
the majority I can say anecdotally the
majority of contacts do remain in the
community
once the team is deployed in the
community or or where you met them in
the residents or the because it's
different right the community could be
somewhere not at home
yes so
um they find some resolution where they
can have their needs met
at home or you know where where they're
at at their workplace
and we representative
I'm just trying to understand the slide
seven percentages so it says about a
third of the seven thousand result in
Mobile requests but then it talks about
42 percent and 18 percent
in terms of breakouts for kids and
adults 42 8 of what of the 31 percent
yes so but that adds up to like six
sixty percent
of that seven thousand
but only thirty percent
total in the second line there
it's so if I may is the 31 of the total
twenty two thousand to get down to the
seven thousand yes okay that's how I
read it oh okay that's oh that's
different slide
gotcha
I will check that second statistic
and we'll make it more clear because
that that's a very good point thank you
the um other thing Mr chair I wanted to
mention is that we also have some
limited crisis Apartments so if a mobile
team has access to that that may be a
result of where someone can go so that
they can be safe until they can take the
next step so those are stays that are
about up to up to seven days where
someone can be safe and not have to
re-enter an unsafe location
so so you're challenging one of my
assumptions I I have thought of the
Behavioral Health crisis response team
as moving to help an individual
experiencing Behavioral Health crisis
removing them from their environment
where there may be other people involved
who are aggravating that is is one thing
but but then you but then you're
suggesting that just putting them in an
apartment for seven day up to seven days
may actually help stabilize a Behavioral
Health crisis I I don't I don't get that
absolutely it's staffed those are those
crisis apartments aren't just apartments
that are empty and waiting they're
stabbed so they have the opportunity to
have continued services and then they
also can get appointments with the
Community Mental Health Center for that
stabilization or are they staffed 24 7
are they just as needed so if you have
somebody who needs it you can staff it
based on that or are we paying for
somebody to hang out at the apartment
all the time no well um we are not
paying for Staffing 24 7 if they're if
it's empty but they do bring in people
when there are people who are in need of
that service
so if I recall the way the mobile
Response Team conversation one is every
legislator would say okay that's great
but where's mine
so are these apartments
distributed enough to where all the
senators are going to be happy that
there's adequate apartment availability
in their neighborhood
not at this time those were required as
part of the standing those up for the
settlement agreement in those three
communities and those are all state
funded those aren't are they
supplemented by federal money no there
it's all state money
okay where there'd be the be that
federal funds okay and and and and so do
you haven't not today but just so you
know when we're talking about money I'm
I'm probably going to want to ask you if
you have any sort of performance metrics
if we're spending a million dollars a
year on apartments how do we know that
that's money being spent effectively did
we positively influence the outcome of
that patient you know
um just an Effectiveness metric of some
kind but uh representative Hull
thank you
um on this slide seven again right I I
can understand how you got to the 31
percent that math was pretty clear the
42 and 18 though
wasn't real clear where what you were
basing that number on so when you update
this slide I'm assuming that's the
percentage of of the seven thousand
eighty four contacts is split but that
math doesn't work so exactly thank you
we will check on that thank you
okay this is really helpful I I we would
be doing this if we had a spreadsheet in
front of us too so I'm glad we're
getting this done a little earlier so
so would you like us to go over the
finances we're just talking about as
they relate to contracts
and if you don't want us to that's fine
no I'm okay with that I I just uh what
the way I describe this uh to to Mr
White is that we know the governor's
budget hasn't come out you know that we
know that you got an agency request that
the governor may change and and so we
just didn't want to get you in an
awkward spot getting you out on the line
about money
that might be different so so I wanted
to hear everything you wanted to say
about the program and the effectiveness
and your concerns and you know where you
see new money going where you see we
could cut back without converting it to
dollars
so we then should just wrap it up with
um talking about the model that we
modeled this after and the three pillars
of that model which I will have Julianne
explain and where that request is to
fulfill those three pillars okay
so this model was built after it's
called the national crisis now model
it's the national best practice for
crisis services and what and it's
comprised of these three kind of pillars
of Crisis Support so the access do we
have a picture on one of the handouts
where where would I be looking yeah
yeah represent the three pillars so it's
the someone to call text or chat someone
to respond and somewhere to go so in New
Hampshire we've done an excellent job
we're really ahead of the curve in in
building out our crisis contact center
our mobile deployment teams and so it's
that third pillar of somewhere to go one
thing I I want to underscore about the
importance of this system is that the
messaging around it is that we want
people to call early and call often that
we don't want people to get to a point
where they are in such acute stress that
they feel like they need Hospital level
of care or a mobile deployment team the
point of this system really is for
people to reach out and for us to help
engage them earlier on in in their
struggles and so our Focus moving into
this next year is evaluating our current
system how you know how how is it
running to date and looking for
opportunities to expand these
location-based centers which means
um just as it sounds it's a it's a
building where individuals can walk in
and see people that day that time it's
potentially an opportunity for law
enforcement to drop off
um as opposed to a jail or a hospital
and so we are exploring models that
would work here in New Hampshire
do you do you think your budget Maps
into these three pillars like if I
wanted to know okay show me the part of
the budget that deals with the text Chat
Show me the part of the budget dealing
with the response is just do do the does
the budget align with your
organizational three pillar concept
I should defer to our CFO on that but
you will see them as part of our
contracts with providers so they're
embedded with that within that but we
certainly are going to pull out
um something like this so that you have
the opportunity to to see where it sits
okay did you have yes go ahead
representative Waller thank you
so I mean we hear a lot about the
numbers of people waiting in the
emergency rooms of our hospitals
how has this affected that number
and do you go sometimes to the do you
get called to the emergency rooms
so to answer your second question first
yes
um we want to see that less and less and
less but it does happen and to answer
your first question I think that New
Hampshire hospital will be presenting
just behind us we believe that there
have been
um hundreds of diversions and we just
know the demand is really high right now
and I I know that the Community Mental
Health Centers have been talking about
the Staffing challenges that they have
and that part of that challenge
um a uh really impacts what's known as
the back door of New Hampshire hospital
and again I I think that um Jasper can
respond to that as well but we I mean
that's the whole point of this program
is and as Julianne said we want people
to call
um earlier
um in the process so that they don't
have to be hospitalized and go on that
trajectory to New Hampshire hospital on
a higher level of care
so so far we're going to guess an answer
to representative Waller's question I
would say at least the one I heard is
that is that the presence of these
mobile response crisis teams probably as
the unintended consequence of driving up
the backlog of people in the ERS waiting
to get to the New Hampshire hospital not
because you're creating additional
patients but because you're bringing
additional patients into the the full
patient flow and and although it's not a
desirable outcome one of the unintended
outcomes is in fact we're this is an
area where we may be exacerbating a
problem appropriately
I would not characterize it as that I
think there are other factors that are
going on that are creating that wait
list and again
um the experts are behind me however
they has been limited
um staffing issues that have um that uh
have impacted the number of beds that
are available as well as housing you
know when you want to do a throughput
and you have an emergency room you have
an acute Psychiatric Center and then you
have housing so you do a throughput when
you have a diminished capacity
in any one of those then you have you
have an issue so we know that there has
to be a focus on that housing piece as
people transition and housing is is an
area of great focus and great need right
now
uh representative Mooney have been
waiting
Mr chair and thank you both for being
here speaking of housing this is a good
segue do you have a breakdown of how
many those without homes use service
through your mobile crisis unit
so that's something that we would have
to come back so you mean individuals who
are unhoused who come who so are we
responding for individuals who are
homeless correct yeah we all have to get
that data thank you very much
representative
back to your budget breakdown so can we
expect now that you've been through
someone to call someone to respond and
you've got numbers for those can we
expect to see in the budget that's
coming forth for somewhere to go
component as well
we hope so
um so we'll put it there so it's in our
prioritized need which you'll see
um when you when you get the budget
details so we did include some funding
for that
hmm
you have exactly 10 mobile response
teams one perk
area
so are you collecting the metrics to
where you could come in here and make an
argument that we need a second one
somewhere or or you know what we don't
really need that one there so the three
um regions Concord Manchester and Nashua
technically have two teams it's they
have a higher Staffing ratio than the
other regions of the state so our our
regions are adjusting their Staffing
ratios based on the deployment requests
that they're getting but every region is
contracted for at least one full and by
following you know a 24 7 Staffing
structure for one at least one team
all right any other questions
okay so this was really good this is
very useful uh before you go is are you
the one that that gave us the New
Hampshire 10-year mental health plan
okay so so we have uh some new people to
the committee would you just give us you
know the sort of an executive summary of
what this is and what it does without
getting into the details of what's in it
so yes the 10-year mental health plan it
was published in January 2019 as a way
for us to examine gaps and opportunities
in our mental health system so it really
set the vision it was driven by
legislative desire and Advocates to
really see a plan for how we address the
mental health needs of our state and so
it set forward core recommendations as
well as overarching goals that we have
been working to accomplish since it's it
was published and so what you see in
terms of the one-page handout are the
accomplishments to date and it's very
comprehensive in some areas very
aspirational but we've been able to
focus on some concrete areas that span
the full Continuum of care for
individuals across the lifespan
look okay so I got distracted by the
word uh recommendation at each of them
so this is a previous recommendation
from the an earlier time frame and then
the bullets underneath it are meant to
say what the success was of those
recommendations
so so then this sort of what's the
appetite to say what are what are the
fresh recommendations and of the fresh
recommendations where are they and and
which ones do you need or think you need
legislative support
so thank you for that question because
this is something that we want to engage
in we want to attend your plans a
10-year plan and we don't want to put it
on a shelf and we need to take another
look at it this was pre-covered
obviously and it was you know three
years ago seems like a real I guess yeah
um four years ago is a really long time
and things change on the ground
situations change so we want to take a
fresh look at it to see what's missing
we currently have a contract with um our
going to be doing a study of looking at
the gaps in our current system not just
for mental health services but for
substance misuse Services as well so
that may inform and really help Drive
our plans going forward so we don't want
to say oh look you know
four years ago we sat around and here's
what we planned we want to refresh it
and and look at it anew
so I think that's all brilliant I I just
see it out of sync with the budget cycle
so how are we going to connect this to a
budget cycle are we going to wait two
years to hear that or you you can't you
can't get it to us by the end of March
probably
so
um I'll probably be kicked for saying
this but not all of this would require
additional dollars any changes some
changes we love hearing that you can say
that yeah but behind me they may so it
may be redirecting dollars and seeing
what our efforts have been and where
they need to go
um and and so no it doesn't perfectly
align for new budgetary items but it
certainly is something that we can't set
aside for two years so you'll see our
efforts around the location-based
Services we're going to try to do that
within some given dollars and within the
budget and not necessarily ask for huge
new amounts of dollars so we'll see that
play out but we really need to get
stakeholder input on where the efforts
need to okay fantastic thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair so I was I'd actually
read your summary sheet previously and I
just went and tied it to the actual
10-year plan which has
14 recommendations so have you actually
made progress on all the recommendations
in the original 10-year plan
yes to some extent yeah that's awesome
yeah that's fantastic
thank you
any other questions from the legislators
uh any final parting thoughts for us
just that I really want to give all the
credit to our providers and to our
communities who have stood up these
services and are working every single
day to address the needs they're the
ones out there doing it we we're the
ones who get to be appearing before you
and talking about it but I just want to
give them credit
so do you do you to what extent
are you concerned or unconcerned about
the the ebbing of the federal money that
we've been pumping into the communities
to help build out the support systems in
the communities and with that money
going away
what's going to happen to our
community-based services do you what do
you think about that just general
problem
thank you for that question it's um one
that we wanted to address on the front
end of receiving those dollars we were
given in the fiscal committee approved
accepted additional funds for our
supplemental block grant dollars which
you'll see when it comes into this
division we made the decision conscious
decision to use those as one-time funds
and really invest them in infrastructure
that wouldn't be ongoing costs so in
almost every instance that's where we
did we didn't just expand services and
with the knowledge that that could be
you know that there's an end and we
didn't want to have a cliff so we made
those as investment dollars
that's outstanding that sounds like
something I heard the governor say once
that we were going to use one-time money
for one-time Investments it's really
great that it got to the operational
level thank you thank you so much
okay with that I think we're ready for
the New Hampshire hospital
thank you uh you're you're leaving
representative hole
who did we designate to take your place
while you're away anyone anyone
are you going to watch the video
could you could you just augment your
notes with what you pick up in the video
I don't know that we have a time crunch
for turning in arm okay
please thank you
hello hello good afternoon I am Ellen
Lapointe I'm the CEO at New Hampshire
hospital and I'll let Cindy introduce
herself I'm Cynthia babonis and I am the
director of social work at New Hampshire
hospital
so thank you for having us today and
giving us the opportunity to tell you a
little bit about what we do we're going
to start with talking about New
Hampshire hospital of course but you're
receiving two PowerPoint presentations
the first is New Hampshire hospital and
the second is Glen Cliff home
in my role I oversee not only New
Hampshire hospital but also Glenn Cliff
home as well as the 16 bed transitional
housing program in the Philbrook
building called The Path program
and soon to be overseeing once it's
built and occupied the New Hampshire
forensic Hospital which you'll also hear
a little bit about as part of the New
Hampshire hospital presentation
so I'll start us off on the first slide
for New Hampshire hospital just a little
bit about who we are we are a secure
inpatient psychiatric treatment facility
supporting adult citizens who suffer
from acute severe and persistent mental
illness we do not serve youth or
adolescent population at New Hampshire
hospital any longer I understand you
heard from Hampstead Hospital at some
point in the recent history and that is
where that population is currently
served in the state
New Hampshire hospital is the largest
psychiatric Treatment Facility in New
Hampshire and we are equipped to care
for the most severely mental ill
patients in the state there are six
other designated receiving facilities
seven actually if you include Hampstead
Hospital
and the capacity that they have is
between 6 to 16 beds so obviously
relatively small capacity in comparison
to New Hampshire hospital
our mission at New Hampshire hospital is
to help citizens with acute mental
illness stabilize their conditions and
live their best lives
our vision at New Hampshire I'm sorry I
think you may have said it but I'm I'm a
visual person what does did you tell us
what uh your census is designed for and
what you're what your current capability
is with beds and Staffing I have that
that our current um stuffing our current
capacity from a clinical perspective is
to serve adults with severe and
persistent mental illness in the state
and I'll talk more about our capacity as
well as our Staffing Resources as we
move forward okay
um so not to read to you the entire
vision statement but please know that
our vision statement is important to us
and part of our vision statement has to
do with supporting our staff and really
wanting to be an employer of choice to
be able to attract and maintain Staffing
numbers that can help support this
significant level of care our core
values of course are also very embedded
in the work that we do you can see those
here on that slide and we really take
those into account when we're making a
hospital-wide decisions in how we care
for the patients so
um so here's the slide that talks a
little bit more about New Hampshire
hospital staff in current state there
are
733 total staff members of which 624 of
them are New Hampshire hospital or state
staff members state employees of Cindy
and I being two of them and 109 of them
are Dartmouth or other agency staff
members so Dartmouth is our clinical
provider contract provider and they
serve in the capacity of all of the MDS
that are providing patient care at New
Hampshire hospital so all of the
um
psychologists all of the family medicine
and clinical practice doctors all of
them are Dartmouth employees
state employees can be made up of some
aprns we have some medical aprns that
are state employees but the remainder of
the aprns are also also Dartmouth
employees so that's why you see such a
high number of Dartmouth employees but
one thing that we're really proud of is
how seamlessly the two organizations
work together to provide patient care
and our medical director his name is at
the bottom of the slide here Dr Jeff
Federer he is also a Dartmouth employee
but he serves as an executive team
member at New Hampshire hospital so
they're represented at that layer as
well so I don't think any of us can help
but to look at a staff number these days
and immediately wonder what the vacancy
rate is sure thank you for that question
so we do have some significant vacancy
rates throughout the hospital our most
significant which is actually on an
upcoming slide in a moment in terms of
some of our barriers at the hospital our
social workers which Cindy oversees as
well as RNs we have thankfully slowly
been able to make some slight progress
in terms of registered nurses However
unfortunately with social workers that
has not been the case and it's actually
gone in the wrong direction for several
factors some of them being vitally
important increase Community Health
needs throughout the state such as in
the school systems we've had some
employees leave to go to other areas of
service to meet mental health needs but
of course that's impacted us at New
Hampshire hospital which is significant
in many ways because the social workers
are really the ones that create
discharge plans
a number for vacancy rate vacancy rates
for nurses is about 45 percent currently
vacancy rates for social workers Cindy
65 percent
you are at a 55 vacancy rate for social
workers 65 65 vacancy so that means you
don't you barely have a third of your
social workers correct
couch
okay so in terms of the clinical teams
who are providing direct patient care
you can see some of the professions that
are listed on there RNS what we call
mhws or mental health workers social
workers psychiatric practitioners and of
course we also have rehab staff members
inclusive of Occupational therapists
um and other other disciplines then of
course we have both clinical and
operational teams you can see there are
several departments listed there we do
have vacancies in these other
departments as well but not nearly as
significant as the two disciplines that
we just spoke about
um at the bottom of this slide you can
see the executive team myself at the
very bottom as the chief executive
officer Cindy is also on that team and
then there's just some additional names
on there for you if you needed to
contact anyone at the hospital you would
know who to ask for
um the next slide just speaks to the
delivery system of the inpatient mental
health care system in the state of New
Hampshire for serious mental illness we
don't have to go through it and find
detail but of course you can see a
citizen might be experiencing a concern
and they go to an emergency room and
they can get sent to let's say Hampstead
Hospital if they meet criteria for there
another designated receiving facility
which I spoke about briefly or New
Hampshire hospital and then you can also
see the additional branches that folks
end up being sent to from these
locations
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
census before I hand it over to Cindy
for the next couple of slides our
current total building capacity for
patients is 185. we have 31 beds offline
due to the workforce shortage which we
meant mentioned moments ago our current
adjusted capacity is 154 that fluctuates
slightly related to covid we're coming
out of a covid concern currently so we
are closer to 150 as of today but we
work very hard at maintaining as high of
a census as possible to make sure that
some of those throughput concerns which
we've already talked about are being
addressed to the best of our ability we
of course continue to prioritize our
efforts not only to increase our
staffing but also to ensure we're using
our resources to the best of our ability
in an attempt to bring additional beds
back online early in January we were at
a capacity of 145 and we move moved to
154 that wasn't because we had a
significant influx of Staff but that was
because we really Dove deeply to look at
the resources that we had and how they
were being utilized throughout the
hospital and through that decision
making we were able to bring those nine
additional beds back online and be able
to use our resources in a way that could
safely support that
we continue to try to make every effort
but of course we don't want to
compromise safety in any way as well so
I'm sorry it just seems to me like
something has got to give right if you
if you if you're dealing with
um you've only closed off somewhere
around 20 percent of your beds you're
dealing with vacancy rates depending on
the
skill set of 45 to 65 percent that's a
huge vacancy rate
so so if the the bed count is high and
the Staffing is low you one would wonder
about quality are we starting to we've
got to see some quality issues if we
don't have the prescribed Staffing level
for a staff to bet what to talk to us
about that sure thank you for that
question so I feel from a clinical
perspective we have you know with the
nurses and mental health workers and the
clinical team members that I mentioned
we have people who are very dedicated to
the safety of the patients and really
paying attention we have a daily safety
huddle every morning during the week to
talk about any safety concerns as
they're being presented throughout the
hospital all of the executive team
participates in that in terms of some of
the areas that we are seeing more
significant concerns related to these
vacancies we'll talk about in a minute
in terms of some of our barriers to
discharge I would say that our vacancies
directly relate to some of the barriers
that we're having to be able to move
patients out of New Hampshire hospital
into another level of care either a step
down or into the community to be able to
be a community a member of their
Community again
so you know in terms of clinical quality
we are joint commission accredited we
work as you know extremely hard in the
safety and care of the patients I don't
feel like we've seen significant
clinical quality concerns
or thankfully an increase in staff
injuries or things of that nature but I
am
fearful in that if we aren't able to
make some Headway in some of these areas
of Staffing that that is a could be a
reality that none of us want to face
sure so the other way that could present
if it's not a quality issue is on a
um a length of stay issue so are you
because of the staffing issues do you
see pressure on increased length of stay
as a result
yeah um I'll I'll let so we have a slide
about that in a moment
um but yes absolutely we do
representative Waller so are you using a
lot of overtime yes we're using a lot of
overtime for nurses and mental health
workers and social workers uh in
particular yes we also have agency Staff
Agency nurses
um in the facility we recently adjusted
we got some feedback from the nursing
staff our chief nursing officer Rosie
did a really thorough review at what you
know what what would make her nurses
happy right what what makes you stay how
can we help support you better so
through that there was a change in their
hours and their shifts that has yielded
some positive results as far as
retention and even recruitment for us
but that only goes so far
could I have a follow-up
um how many agency nurses are you using
at this point I think currently I don't
have the exact number but I believe it's
close to 18.
thank you
um so some of this we already talked
about and I know um you just had some
questions that we will get to in these
next couple of slides so
um Cindy why don't you take it away
so again I'm Cindy I'm the Social Work
Director at New Hampshire hospital I've
been there 22 years so I've seen a lot
of change over time bringing us to where
we are today
um
just to kind of Orient you to admissions
at New Hampshire hospital virtually all
of our admissions are involuntary as the
patients have been deemed too dangerous
for other settings
um
we primarily accept patients from
hospital emergency departments
throughout the state via iaea petition
we also occasionally accept patients
from County jails in the spu secure
psychiatric unit
by Statute we do not accept patients who
are dangerous due to substance use
disorder or intellectual disability
however a lot of patients with mental
illness have co-occurring disorders so a
lot of the folks at New Hampshire
hospital also are dealing with those
challenges
um while designated receiving facilities
are able to accept iea admissions they
defer to New Hampshire hospital for the
most acutely ill violent referrals
barriers to discharge
in 2022 the monthly average number of
patients
stable and awaiting discharge for
greater than 15 days was 62. so every
month that average number of patients
who we are treatment teams deemed no
longer requiring New Hampshire hospital
level of care the average number was 62.
so the lowest month was 57 the highest
was 72.
these numbers adequately represent data
going back prior to 2018 which is when I
started collecting the data
so pre-covered
the number of patients awaiting
discharge has consistently exceeded the
number of patients awaiting admission
commonly known as the queue
I'm sorry I'm just a little slow at a
connection mental dots
is okay with an adjusted capacity of 154
and the number of patients that are
stable and just awaiting discharge
issues of 62
does does that imply a simple math a 154
minus 62 yes you get something in the
90s for those who are being actively
treated and the rest are you know
basically being given room and board
yes okay well thank you for letting me
just say it plainly
um the vast majority of stable patients
awaiting discharge are awaiting
long-term placement in supported
residential settings as they are two at
Baseline when they're as well as they're
going to be they're unable to remain
stable in independent settings even with
the most intensive outpatient support
provided by the Community Mental Health
Center so we have folks who you know
even with the the right medications are
still going to require a certain level
of supervision in the community 24-hour
supervision such as a community
residence a licensed nursing home
assisted living facility
the following are types of supported
housing that exist but are very limited
and it creates wait times that are
several months or longer
as I previously said 24-hour supervised
mental health housing such as Community
residents or what some people refer to
as transitional housing nursing home and
assisted living beds and specialized in
supervised housing for people with
intellectual disabilities
and to just to get back to your question
about the impact of the Staffing
shortage on discharge planning in
particular the the resources in the
community are very limited New Hampshire
hospital has
what should be a large social work
department because it requires social
workers to find the right resources for
these folks in the community and when
the resources are so limited you really
need to be Johnny on the spot when the
bed comes up
and so I don't you're not as much Johnny
on the spot if you have 13 cases instead
of six
um and that's where we're edging up
towards I since I've been at the
hospital most of my career has been in
Direct Care doing the discharge planning
six patients is about what you should
have as a social worker at New Hampshire
hospital these are the most dangerous
people in the state with mental illness
they need a lot of support they need a
lot of good critical thinking and
professionalism and understanding of the
systems
um
so our caseloads going higher and higher
slows down
the frequency that we can call all of
these places in the community you know
instead of calling every day to say do
you have a bed do you have a bed do you
have a bed it's maybe every few days
that you can make that call and it's
just one example
so I'm trying to imagine a average day
in the life of a New Hampshire hospital
social worker with a a patient count of
13. does that mean every day there's
they need to spend some at least one
unit of time with each patient
during that day they're they're spending
some time every day with every patient
under their charge
that would be ideal but it doesn't
that's not practically how it ends up
working out because 13 is a big number
13's too many so and and then when
they're not interacting directly with a
patient it sounds like they're
attempting to coordinate
the services the social determinants of
Health kinds of things exactly we're
finding housing we're referring to group
homes we're calling the landlord to say
please don't evict them we will pay your
back rent for three months just so that
you don't evict them so they have a
place to go when they leave we're
calling the Community Mental Health
Center to say hey please come in and
visit your patient so that you can see
that they're doing well we're updating
them on how their patients are doing
while they're in the hospital we're
coordinating with those outpatient teams
to set up all of the appointments that
the patient needs you know to help make
those recommendations that this person
may need an act team they may need daily
Med monitoring we're drafting their
conditions for discharge we're making
referrals for guardianships we're making
referrals for probate commitments we're
calling defense attorneys to work out
whatever legal problems are getting in
the way of their discharge or the AG's
office to say hey we're letting you know
this person that you said we have to
notify you about when they leave is
leaving
okay so how's morale I I gotta imagine
in an environment where people are just
really wanting to help and that they're
facing
these sort of daily burdens morale's got
to be suffering what what how would you
characterize morale how would you what
are you doing to ameliorate it and and
because the big thing you need is just
more people right but but until then
what are you doing
I am reinforcing that patient care is
first and foremost and quality of care
is first and foremost and so if it takes
you an extra 24 or 48 hours to make that
safe discharge plan happen then that's
what you need to do because what really
hits us the hardest with morale is when
we set up a discharge plan that fails
and someone doesn't do well when they
leave the hospital
so Morel is okay because I support my
staff
and and you you have good feedback
mechanisms once they leave the hospital
and go back to the community you have
good feedback mechanisms to know how
that one of my roles at New Hampshire
hospital as part of the exact team and
the director of social work is that I do
a lot of collaborative meetings with the
community mental health centers on every
level
um and so we get feedback regularly from
all 10 Community Mental Health Centers
area agencies that serve people with
intellectual disabilities on how things
are going in terms of our discharge
planning
um and and how patients are doing as
they leave the hospital and post
discharge
in your techniques your approaches to
efficiency are the same as they probably
were 30 years ago keeping notes on a
piece of paper making phone calls
traveling to do site visits is there
anything about today's technology or the
technology in the next five years to
enable that sort of feedback mechanism
to to be more efficient
well I think covid in a way has helped
us with that at New Hampshire hospital
um
Zoom has been wonderful we serve the
entire State of New Hampshire and so we
have patients from every part of New
Hampshire in the hospital and so we
often now now that we've got
um the capability with technology we'll
do community meetings via Zoom so you
know the patient's family their
Guardians their Community Mental Health
Center can all participate in those
meetings more easily they don't have to
drive
long distances to come to New Hampshire
hospital to be part of that meeting we
can also do intake appointments that way
so in summary what what is what are your
top two or three between the two of you
what are your top two or three
legislature hear us this is what we need
from from you what what what what what
must we do to be of help in this area
um I think that that's a really good
question I would say that your support
of additional housing throughout the
state is a number one priority to be
able to support the patient population
and having safe and appropriate
locations to return to in the community
um and you know if they're if you're
faced with decisions I would say the
second one is if you're faced with
decisions in terms of
um you know budgets for Staffing and for
rates and for anything having to do with
the support of our employees in that
regard that would also be vitally
important
so just to be clear when you say housing
it's not just housing it's it's in your
in this patient mix you need housing
with some wrap around Support Services
almost like a staffed bed you need
something the equivalent you need
staffed housing to help discharge these
people back in the community or is it
simply a vacant apartment it's
um the folks at the Bureau of mental
health which you've already heard from
in in the initiatives in the 10-year
mental health plan
are going to help us with that I mean we
work collaboratively with the Bureau of
mental health because they really
support those Services being stood up in
the community so when they're coming to
ask for support in the services that
they're providing that's actually
helping New Hampshire hospital
okay are there are there other questions
go ahead represent Waller these are just
two really quick ones
um I wondered how many social workers
there are I'm sure it's in here
someplace but I've missed it and are
they all msws or are we are psychiatric
social workers are all Master's level
social workers msws and a good number of
them are licensed social workers and I
feel very strongly about the MSW as the
proper person for the position because
as I stated before it requires a certain
level of professional development and
systems theory
um to understand all of the different
factors everything from benefits to
housing to
knowing all of the different human
resources in the community
are really important and they need to
have that ability to practice
independently
without without me looking over their
shoulder
where are we recruiting
msws from
a lot of msws come around here from UNH
they have a wonderful MSW program but as
with the Mental Health crisis nationally
social workers are in short supply
there's not fewer I don't think it's
just that we need more of them
and how many are how many how many
positions do you have for social workers
so in my department there are roughly
32 positions
um but a lot of them are empty now so
you know
and then if you throw in their
the experience of covet in the last
couple years when you know someone has
to be out for a week and a half
for covid and then folks need vacations
because we don't want them to burn out
thank you
thanks
um
I'm from Nashua so I know that we my
community must have a large or not a
large number must have Supportive
Housing that exists
um
is that housing which is or one of the
end goals to get these patients
um out of New Hampshire hospital
is it
other opportunities relatively balanced
around the state or are there certain
communities that sort of bear the brunt
simply because they have the facilities
Manchester Nashua uh maybe you know on
the Seacoast
um I think it's gotten a little bit
better recently but you're right I mean
there's some communities especially you
know the North country that don't have
as many resources
um
so to some extent it does happen I mean
patients have the
patients at New Hampshire hospital have
the right to live wherever they want to
live I don't I would never tell them
where they have to live but as a matter
of practicality if someone's homeless
you know if if one Community is say it
be Nashua or Manchester or Concord
happens to have more housing inventory
our housings I have someone whose only
job is searching for apartments at New
Hampshire hospital
and she knows where they're available in
the state
um
we're going to tell the patient hey I
know you want to leave and you're ready
to leave there's an apartment in
Claremont right now would do are you
interested in living in Claremont and so
that happens
um
yeah I guess I'm just acknowledging that
you know it's probably often in the
patient's best interest to go back to
their home Community where they have the
support network so I'm just true
wondering how wide that web was but
thank you for your answer
all right do you want to do the forensic
Hospital sure thank you
um as some of you may know New Hampshire
hospital has been working on for the
past year and a half or so with a
architect design firm to design uh the
forensic hospital we were approved for a
24 bed
facility that's going to be physically
attached to New Hampshire hospital so it
won't be a freestanding forensic
hospital it will be an additional unit
of New Hampshire hospital however it
will have its own Staffing model its own
training and education components Etc
that are specific to the forensic
population
um so I put the wrong slide down
so with different you know I think we
may have plunged into this just a little
quickly okay let's come back and for
people who have not heard the term
forensic hospital but let's let's talk
about what that is
that's kind of the criminally insane
category isn't it so um
there are patients that are involved in
the criminal justice system and are
suffering from a severe mental illness
that could be folks that are incompetent
to strand trial Not Guilty by reason of
insanity
um patients who haven't committed
unlawful acts but because of their
mental illness are too dangerous to be
treated in a conventional hospital
patients of that nature okay and so to
fast forward through the history that
currently they've been at the state
hospital excuse me State Prison we've
had lots of issues with lawsuits and
whether or not we think it meets our own
standards of care and so the
determination was made in the last
legislature to go ahead and and build a
replacement Center for for this we
decided to co-locate it with the New
Hampshire hospital to gain some
efficiencies of scale and cooperation
and and if that's all a good summary
then I'll just ask you
um how we're doing are we on track when
when is this thing going to open are we
on time are we on budget
thank you for those questions so
according to the original timeline we
had the opening slated with occupancy
for the summer of next year the summer
of 2024. at this point in time we are
nearing the end of our design and
development phase of the project through
that design and development we have
determined that there's some
foundational work that needs to occur to
be able to ensure obviously the
foundation of the facility being secure
and that foundational work will take
some additional time based on the fact
that New Hampshire hospital is already
occupied and we don't want to limit or
minimize the occupancy of New Hampshire
hospital due to this project the other
component that is being taken into
consideration now that we're getting
closer to putting the project out to bid
within the next couple of weeks with the
construction company is that the current
environment and current state in terms
of construction and resources and
availability of products and materials
is still constrained so as far as DHHS
in our planning to operate New Hampshire
the forensic facility we're on target
get with that but due to some of these
concerns it will take more than likely
an additional year to be able to occupy
it and have it be completely constructed
so that's the summer of 25. since we're
trying to build this in a swamp yeah uh
I understand the foundational issues is
there a possibility that somebody could
say this isn't going to work we need
another site no I don't think so I I
think that they feel confident the
majority of the concern has to do with
the fact that New Hampshire hospital is
already occupied and some of the
drilling and boring and things that they
have to do would be very disruptive so
they have to go about it in a way that
makes sense to accommodate the current
need so I'm not I'm not looking to like
beat anyone up but we're you're we're
going to end up being a year behind the
original plan behind the original
timeline yes yeah okay all right
um
representative Waller when when it
finally is finished and we move the um
people from the prison over to the
facility will the staff from the prison
come to the facility with them or do you
anticipate hiring new staff for the
forensic unit that's a great question so
in terms of the forensic hospital and
the S the current spu there's only a
portion of spu patients who are actually
going to be transitioning to New
Hampshire hospital and those are the
patients that meet the criteria that I
just talked about in terms of their
mental illness there still will be an
existence and a necessity of the spu to
continue to operate based on the
Department of Corrections needs and the
needs of that population that they serve
so we don't anticipate
um having you know we're not planning to
have any staff from Doc we don't want to
we don't wanna you know further limit
their their ability to deliver the
services that they deliver either so we
would be looking to hire
um our own staff to be able to support
the forensic Hospital
I just have a comment for you and it
goes back to the first slide on on our
mission
okay so so what I think your mission
includes it's not in here
is because you're you're in the middle
of the patient throughput from the
emergency rooms into the community you
see the the sort of the input problems
you have and back up at the ERS you see
the output problems that you have we're
trying to find places in the community
it's not in your mission but my
expectation on HHS oversight and in here
is that you you all are in the very best
position to be observing and managing
and coordinating that workflow problem
you know and so although it's probably
nowhere in the statutory Charter for you
to be worried about you know knowing
what you need to know about that ER
backlog or knowing what you need to know
about the ability to of community
services I don't know anyone else that
would be in a better position than you
all to get be able to give us feedback
because we got to get that system
straightened out and cleaned out so that
we can move people you know into the
level of service they need when they
need it without delay
and and and so I know that's not your
official Charter but I I just would hope
that you would you would own that
just
that is actually
the social work department and
the code of ethics for social work is
that people should be treated in the
least restrictive environment possible
that's so that they can live the
their life as independently as they
deserve to
so that's that's not a new part of our
mission it's been part of what we do for
as long as I've worked there and long
before that
that's part of your kind of your
clinical Mission your altruistic Mission
you know I'm talking about Mission and
the Army sense you know thou Thou shalt
be able to deliver reports on demand
about the status of the throughput you
know that that that level is what I'm
talking about and that's not your
obligation but we do we are working on
those metrics so to be able to report
out on what the barriers are to
discharge how many people are waiting
for each of those levels of care okay
um that stuff that it that we do have
some of now and can and working actively
to develop more thank you representative
Mooney thank you Mr chair and thank you
again both for being here I know we're
all busy
um however I get the sense that you have
an extraordinary amount of things on
your plate this forensic hospital are
you the project manager on it or are
there other entities that are helping
out in term terms of this project thank
you thank you for the question there's
several entities that are helping with
this project I am a steering committee
member but thankfully I'm not acting
solely in any of its oversight and I'm
getting support from the commissioner's
level as well
I'm thankful for that as well thank you
any other questions in this area are you
the Glenn Cliff crew as well
and Cindy's welcome to stay but all
right hey thank you for your testimony
okay so uh we're we're behind and it's
it's because I'm talking so much but uh
if you could
um let's let's get through Glen Cliff
it's sort of a slightly higher level
because there's more details in the
slides and and so talk to us about the
uniqueness of the of the mission tell us
about you know your your your bed
capacity and vacancy rates tell us about
sort of your strategic concerns over the
next five years on Building Maintenance
replacement
expansion you know uh more more more
high level than than down into the weeds
sure absolutely thank you so
um I as you as I previously mentioned I
help oversee Glenn Cliff home um Todd
Bickford is the long-term care
administrator there he has a leadership
team who also supports him
um and they start their mission is to
strive to provide a Continuum of service
to New Hampshire's developmentally
disabled and or mentally ill population
in the home-like atmosphere with an
emphasis on Independence dignity and
acceptance I would invite anyone and
Todd Todd would say the same if he were
here to go up to Glencliff if you ever
had the chance he loves to host visitors
it's a beautiful campus beautiful
facility in self-sustained which I'll
talk about more in a second are these
folks there on an involuntary invitation
or are they all voluntary through a
guardian of some kind
um they are their generally voluntary
through a guardian and obviously
requiring a nursing home level of care
that that is provided in that
environment so only only residing there
um via having the need to reside in that
environment not kind of a at a directive
of of anyone
okay
um so glencliffe home is a healthcare
facility it provides a Continuum of
services for New Hampshire residents as
I mentioned previously
um they are a center for Medicare and
Medicaid services certified facility and
as I previously mentioned in terms of
Eligibility there has to be a pass are
or a long-term care eligibility approval
screening in order for them to be able
to reside there
um they are located 69 miles Northwest
of Concord uh nestled on the side of
Mount mussolak in the town of Benton it
was the facility in itself was built in
1906 and they are off the grid so
they're a self-sustained campus which
produces all of their own electricity
using a combination of hydropower and
diesel generators they also produce all
their own hot water and a steam heating
bio generator power plant has its own
potable water supply and sewage system
so they maintain a very independent
campus
uh you can see in the next slide similar
to the New Hampshire hospital
presentation where they fall in the
mental health system
and I won't go through each individual
but they're all very highly skilled you
can see the title in the tenures of the
Glencliff comb um key leaders I do want
to spend a moment talking about their
staff and their vacancies which you
asked about Mr chairman they have 168
full-time State positions currently
there's 60 vacancies or a 36 percent
vacancy rate
51 part-time State positions they have
51 part-time State positions and
currently 32 vacancies or a 63 vacancy
rate
currently they have five contracted
nurses as well as the medical director
their medical director is also a
Dartmouth employee similar to New
Hampshire hospitals set up
other non-employee providers include
their Primary Care aprns registered
dietitians and of course their rehab
staff
eligibility we don't have to obviously
go through these in detail but there is
specific eligibility that needs to be
met in order for someone to reside at
Glen Cliff home
um
one of those is really
you know significant in that these
individuals are referred to other
nursing homes throughout the state and
need to be declined admission to those
facilities before becoming eligible to
be at Glencliff home
um obviously the department in the state
works hard as was previously mentioned
having these individuals reside in their
community of choice
so at times they end up needing to
reside at Glencliff home due to criteria
that other nursing facilities aren't
capable of managing and oftentimes that
has to do with their mental illness or
disabilities
um there are currents on the wait I'm
sorry I'm just jumping ahead on the wait
list where there's 26 on the wait list
that that don't work were those 26 you
got 38 and then 12 of them are in the
New Hampshire hospital what what's going
on with the other 26. so my
understanding of the other 26 are
individuals who are residing in other
nursing homes currently in those nursing
homes believe that they need a different
level of care to support their mental
illness they also could be residing in
hospitals needing long-term care
placement but being those hospitals
being unsuccessful in their ability to
discharge them to other community
nursing homes
foreign
unattended
independent and to the point where
they're danger to themselves or others
no um generally those individuals who
would be a danger to themselves or
others would be at New Hampshire
hospital first and they would make up
the 12 individuals that you see
currently on the wait list thank you
um so their current census as of
yesterday is 70 when they are fully
staffed they have the capacity for 120.
currently they're capped capacity is at
75 and that is due to their Staffing
constraints that I previously mentioned
primarily nursing staff RN and LPN staff
some lnas as well
um they do receive numerous calls and
inquiries about the availability
um but they but glencliffe home does
have to inform individuals that there is
often a wait time up to or sometimes
over a year for individuals to be able
to receive a bet at glencliffe
some other important information which
speaks to some of the capital needs and
some of the facilities maintenance and
sustainability that you asked about Mr
chair
they have a number of ongoing Capital
project needs currently one of them is a
roofing project
and that is inclusive of half of the
resident housing portion of their main
building
they also are working on an electrical
enhancement which will double double
their hydroelectric output and
um desire to install Steam turbines and
that goal is to support 85 percent of
the campus
electricity will be renewable or free
which is
important
um and their potable water upgrade for
three million dollars which creates a
more secure system with backup sources
so so these are literally in the capital
budget and not we're not doing General
funds on any of these this is
situational awareness so we know what's
going on correct okay that's good do we
um what what sort of the the long-term
planning on facility replacement
are we 20 years away from needing a new
building a different building are we 50
years I mean if this was built in 1906
this is an aging real estate stock
yeah um it I'm not I'm not really sure I
can answer that question but I can say
that you know the department does
try to put Capital needs forward and be
able to get them addressed via the
capital budget to continue to help
support Glenn Cliff's operational
capability there is a budget that was
put forth in this most recent budget
cycle that fully funds their continued
operations so yes it is aging and yes
they are starting to see some increased
facility based needs however
you know the the department is
supporting those needs to the best of
its ability to keep them operational
okay so someday I'd like to hear when we
think we're going to have to start
replacing buildings
all right do we have any other questions
you do you think you hit the high high
points uh
I think so uh
you know if folks have questions about
Glencliff home um Todd Bickford is
always happy to talk about the facility
always happy to give tours it's a
beautiful campus they do a really a
tremendous job up there in their care
and support of what are sometimes very
challenging and difficult residents to
care for and
yeah they do a phenomenal job so because
you're so isolated I gotta imagine you
have harder trout time filling vacancies
than other facilities that it's hard to
get to your facility they do have some
significant vacancy concerns but one of
the really nice things that is on their
side when it comes to vacancy is that
campus actually also has housing for
agency staff there's additional houses
you can see from the bird's eye view of
the campus there's a number of
facilities or buildings located on that
campus some of which actually their
nursing agency staff reside in for the
duration of their agency contract so
that really has been helpful for them to
be able to maintain a decent level of
Staffing with agency utilization and
those agency nurses not having to pay
for housing for the duration of their
contract
any questions
just quickly I'm looking ahead at the
the future needs and challenges and the
fact that
um again on my previous statement about
keeping patients connected to their
Community Family and support network
no cell service no Wi-Fi
which is to me heartbreaking that these
people have no connection to those that
love them
um but yet I imagine the staff has Wi-Fi
so what are some of the are you saying
no no the staff doesn't have Wi-Fi how
does the how do you function without
so there's not a guest network but there
is Wi-Fi that is able to support the
state computer-based systems okay yeah
yes do you have sorry do you have an
idea of what step up could be would be
needed to
expand
um well I know Dave Wieters is here from
the IT department
um so I'm not I'm not sure in my role if
there's been any work or assessment done
to be able to enhance that network but
that's fine thank you
yours is a valid concern and we had a
similar issue two years ago when we
started looking at the veterans home
that they they didn't really have Wi-Fi
support for the patients they had it for
the staff and for the operations but
they since we're able to take some
federal money and upgrade and I think
they put in a separate wi-fi system for
the patients so I I Mr wieders is here
you can correct everything I just said
so representative Waller do you have
just a really quick one
um I know that
these are elderly patients many of them
but I remember a couple of years ago
when
we're talking about glencliffe that they
were starting to have a program where
they were doing some discharge and is
that still is that still happening yes
absolutely
um it's not very it's not extremely
frequent that residents discharge from
that facility but absolutely if the
opportunity presents itself or there's
something closer to home for that
individual or their level of care is
able to be met due to family
circumstances and in their actual home
environment then they would absolutely
work on discharging those individuals
I don't know I my instinct on that is
that 85 90 probably expire while
residents uh and don't get discharged
I would say that's probably pretty close
to Accurate yeah okay
okay uh thank you so much
and now I think we're ready for I the it
minute
go ahead introduce yourself and let's go
good afternoon my name is David Wieters
I'm the information Services director
for DHHS and in partnership with the
state of New Hampshire we
we do almost of all of our I.T work with
commissioner Goulet in the department of
Information Technology so I'll let him
introduce himself
good afternoon uh Mr chair and members
of the committee uh great to be here
so
um
the fun thing about Information Services
in it is we touch just about everything
so it can be very complex I will try not
to use any three-letter acronyms stop me
if there's anything that I'm getting too
technical on as we go forward but one of
the things I'd like to make sure that we
impress upon this this committee is that
all the services and programs that we
offer throughout DHHS are dependent upon
technology
so without those the technology we do
have difficulties actually providing for
that efficiency and point-of-care
solutions
and so when you go through the budget
you'll see a large line item for class
27 transfer over to the Department of
Information Technology and it's just one
line item in our budget but several line
items and doit's budget
and and then also throughout the budget
you'll see components in the programs
that are talking about their I.T systems
like the Medicaid management information
system and whatnot that is also funded
in our budget so it can be more complex
and it's hard for us to point it out we
usually do point it out as we go through
our presentations during the budget
season sessions
so with that the on the second slide is
really our agenda today I'm gonna look
to you for cues in terms of time because
I know we're a little bit past our
original scheduled time so you tell me
to speed up or slow down as you need me
so so I I I am going to ask you to go a
little out of order if you don't mind I
can certainly do that if we if we could
maybe start on page 13. because because
at the end of this presentation
what what I'm what I'm what I'm trying
to understand is the extent to which uh
you're you're integrated with the
management the Senior Management of the
Department of Health and Human Services
you have to look at because I'm speaking
with my hands
okay so there we have the Strategic
vision and priorities of the
commissioner of the DHHS and the
leadership team establishing these are
the things we must do
and the I.T people coming in because I I
think this is the way you think is for
every strategic initiative the I.T
implications and support plan has to be
in place and for the commissioner's
priorities there needs to be an I.T
priority and we chunk down that list of
support until we get to the point where
there's all that other stuff that has to
be done just on a day-to-day basis to
keep everything running you know that
doesn't necessarily map into her
priorities but Maps into just keeping
the office open so I want to understand
the extent to which uh you are you are
hearing the the Commissioners strategy
and how you're supporting the
commissioner's strategy and then if
you're having problems with resourcing
or Personnel because everyone's short
something right so do you have enough
project managers how you're doing that
I'm look that's the that's the Strategic
lay down I'm trying to to get today and
maybe maybe starting at 13 may be a good
spot yes
so commissioner Goulet is going to kick
it off I'll kick that off and I'll let
David uh do the color commentary
um you know our strategic planning
starts with
um you know we do uh we have a published
strategic plan out on our doit website
that's publicly available and we we um
rev that every two or three years and
it's a very high level plan and
and it what it does is it considers the
Strategic plans or the Strategic plans
for each agency by Statute I can't
remember the statute now but each agency
is required to do a what they call it
Agency information technology plan or
aitp is what we call it so
um what what DHHS and other agencies do
is we we work with them to create this
aitp which is a reflection of business
priorities
uh put into it lingo so we start with
the business we move to it as you you
had pointed out the the overall
Statewide strategic plan looks at the
common themes across all agencies
particularly the large ones and
and then there's some obvious ones like
cyber security is a pillar in our
overall strategic plan because we have
to do that we couldn't survive without
it so that it's it's a pretty well
um it's a pretty well
um done process I think and we keep
trying to evolve it each biennium we do
this fully on a biennial basis so what
you should expect is that when an agency
comes in with a budget request that um
that is say additional or whatever it
should align with the agency Information
Technology plan and be supported by the
overall Statewide strategic plan as well
and thank you for that that that's good
context and the thing that's driving my
wanting to to bring this up in front of
division three is uh the the accumulated
experience on the fiscal committee where
an individual item will come in and
there'll be an I.T component to it and
the IT component will on paper look like
oh yeah we're going to put some money
and we've got some manpower to do it and
we're just going to go do this thing to
support this this this initial this one
initiative
we don't we don't have context at that
point of the transaction of where that
initiative fits into the big picture
we're we're getting like buckshot
IT projects all over the place and just
this overall sense
I have I'm left with is how how is all
of this ran seeming Randomness being
managed in a strategic construct and or
is it and I'm sure it is because you're
both really good but
so that's what's been driving me for
this today's briefing is to understand
you know like like so so when dcyf shows
up and they they and and in their budget
they're talking about dcyf money and
they say but we have this I.T thing we
want to do
um I I want to know that there's a way
to to go from that it project in that
department in that department and tie it
into the big picture what you're doing
from an I.T management perspective
and I'm not I'm not meaning to throw you
off I'm just trying to let you know if
we don't get there today that's okay
that's it's just that's where I where I
want us to be able to have conversations
sounds good Mr chairman I think if you
let me start from a little bit closer to
the beginning you'll understand some of
the structure that we do have in place
like the project management office our
security privacy components and how that
all filters into when dcyf has a request
for comprehensive travel for information
system how does that get onto our list
to support them and move it forward to
completion to provide those services but
I will go quickly through those first
like 10 slides and then we can jump in
right into the division I.T does that
work
so
starting on the third slide fourth slide
there Information Services
so the information Services team which
is part of the ocom division
um within DHHS is really has 20 people
and we those 20 people are really
leaders in the organization to help
facilitate Information Services going
forward and we we use what's called
Matrix management and that's a common
term in I.T but really there's
Information Services leads and managers
throughout every division moving I.T
Solutions forward with their doit
partners
so these five areas that you have that
you see in front of you strategic
planning design and interoperability is
really focused at a high level the 50
000 foot level to try to understand what
are those business decisions that we're
doing like a forensic science a forensic
Hospital coming forward what is that
going to impact us from an I.T
perspective well when we were looking at
the acquisition of Hampstead Hospital
how are we going to look at that and
make sure that they're effective day one
when we come on when they come on board
so that that group really engages pretty
quickly with the uit and the in the
bureaus and the divisions to move it
forward
the project management office which you
were sort of alluding to in terms of
process of getting how do we prioritize
is really made up of nine people with
with a pmo director employing the best
practices and the next steps of where
we're going with um project management
and that's working with all the
different what we call resource managers
as well as the division directors to say
what's a priority for you and how does
that play in with all the other work
workload that we have in the
organization we've been working on that
for the past year year and a half really
diligently in the past five years
through lean processing as well as
project management and I think we're
really at the the precipice or the
Tipping Point to be able to start
delivering on those best practices in
this next coming year next coming
biennium
the last three that you see there
information security and awareness that
team right now is it has three employees
one there's only one position currently
filled to vacant and it partners with
the privacy officer that I know you
heard from uh commission interim
commissioner Weaver the other day Kathy
Bernhardt is our privacy officer to
really understand the Privacy first and
the security
components of all of our I.T systems as
well as our practices so security isn't
just technology it's where do we put
this piece of paper at the end of the
day if it has somebody's health record
on it we need to make sure that it's
locked up and maintained so that uh just
no just only the people that need access
can have access to it
and then the last two Enterprise
business intelligence really that's
where you get your real reports your
data analytics your understanding of the
information and the services we're
performing it's working with multiple
other teams to put those reports
together and the infrastructure to
support it
and then rounding out the group we have
the application Hardware lifecycle
management just a case in point like
you'll hear this probably throughout the
budget season we are at 30 vacancy in
that group and so it is difficult to
manage and facilitate new Solutions when
you're you're also short staffed
I want to jump ahead on an item and and
we can come back to your flow I want to
I want to do just a little drill down
into Enterprise business intelligence
and and you got you got three employees
there and what's your vacancy rate in
there right now that one's full and we
have all all of them filled up and they
are actively working with multiple other
teams throughout the department so so
skipping ahead then I I think slide 11
is is your uh your effort to explode
what what's happening with that
Enterprise business intelligence so so
this is this is this is kind of what
these three people do but I'm I'd like
to ask you a little bit about uh kind of
how they do it how they integrate like
like let's say for example
um I'm somebody in the department of
health and or excuse me the department
of insurance or I'm in DHHS somewhere
and I have a strategic information
question and like for example I want to
know the top 10 drugs that we spend
money on in the state and I want to know
how much we spend for how many units of
it you know that that's not an ordinary
query on any one system that sounds to
me like housing capability and the
ability to to to to go ahead and create
that report and to visually to create
the visualization are you able to
support those kinds of requests or not
so the answer Mr chairman is it depends
so different group so we have data
analytics teams embedded in each
division some teams are larger than
others and then we Outsource with
Professional Services organizations to
do some of those Point Solutions so I'll
give you an example opioid crisis and we
had a grant that we got it was called
opioid data to action where we receive
funding from the Center for Disease
Control and prevention to address the
multiple data sources that support
knowledge about the opioid crisis in in
the state of New Hampshire we worked
through a multi-year organization both
with Behavioral Health Division of
Medicaid services and public health as
well as our partners and Secretary of
State for the vital records system to
work through all the privacy concerns
and the components of the data sharing
so that we can ingest that and build our
opioid crisis dashboard but it's not
just one team this team helps lead the
infrastructure the content like the the
content of the contract and helps lead
that direction but we are fully
dependent upon the the program areas as
well as the data analytics and that team
in their teams as well as there's a doit
Enterprise business intelligence team
that is focused on this effort from a
infrastructure perspective
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you why
I'm I'm pulling on this particular
string I I I I think
um I think the corporate world uh and a
lot of Health Care has realized that the
next big wave of innovation and
productivity gains are going to come
through the power of information and and
so what the corporations are have been
doing is that for at least a decade
they've been really working on data
warehousing capabilities and the ability
to do Data Mining and and and I and I
think the ones that are on The Cutting
Edge are are going forward with some Ai
implementations and so so I just I just
want you know we've worked together on
privacy we've worked together on cyber
security I'm just saying that I I if if
we need to I'd be willing to talk to you
and and work with you on what it needs
to what we need to do to have a really
great Enterprise business intelligence
unit
um because with three people I you know
it brings up questions of yeah are they
are they the right three people are they
are they are there jobs described the
way you want them you know and we don't
need to do that in public I I'm just
letting you know this is I think this is
a strategic priority uh for the state if
and maybe the commissioner
uh when when she's got her priorities
listed
no I certainly understand and I would I
would say it's three people in in my
Bureau but it's it's a large amount of
people so we have entire data analytics
team for Medicaid but it's under the
Medicaid Division and so the challenge
with our the way our budget's structured
and the way we present is each of us
present from our our sort of our our
span of control and so I'm I'm giving
you visibility to my team that helps
lead and facilitate but certainly
there's
um
probably I don't know the exact number
but I can get that number of how many
people are working on data analytics and
business intelligence in the department
in conjunction with doat but I do
believe we have the right people and we
have an initiative with the Medicaid
enterprise system strategy to go out to
RFP in the future for a data analytics
Professional Services organization to
augment that work as well in in terms of
your component that you were talking
about are visual intelligence we have
looked at that I think we need to go
through the base infrastructure so most
of the other private sector they started
building the the data analytics and the
business intelligence work and the turn
of the century and they didn't have some
of the privacy concerns so they just
went and grabbed it and put pulled it
together we have to be much more
methodical with what information we can
pull in and how we can combine it
because once it is combined we now we
have to know who we can share that
information with and what and what
information can be garnered from that
can be shared with the public so we have
a I guess another level or layer that
makes it take a little bit longer but I
think it's important for for our
constituents so that we take that those
steps
that's great I guess what I'm imagining
also just like you have your strategic
I.T plan that goes out for many many
years uh I I I assume that you have a
vision of where you want to take the
Enterprise business intelligence
component over the next five to ten
years to sort of keep track with
external benchmarks on on how to manage
corporate data certainly if that's
something that would please the
committee I can go into some of the
details but we certainly from a
technology perspective we we built a
large infrastructure on an oracle back
end with Informatica for extract to
transform and load of the functions and
actually doing the data modeling and the
warehousing and then Tableau for
visualizations but we're also looking at
other tools to expand to create like ad
hoc type reporting like you were saying
where I want to know
based off of all our data sources how
much do we spend on on this drug every
year that level of knowledge requires us
to have all of our data sources in one
data warehouse effectively so so for the
committee's purpose where what we're
teeing up is enough background and
knowledge of your department to let us
get through the two-year budget It's
Complicated by the fact that you know it
is spread all over the department and I
just wanted us to end the day knowing
you know how it all kind of we could map
every piece of I.T in the budget
somewhere into a a framework but on the
longer term aspect of the 10-year
strategy for business intelligence I'd
be happy to talk to you offline on that
sounds good Mr chairman all right uh so
so when I last interrupted you you were
on slide four well and we essentially I
went at a high level for all the slides
all the way up until slide 12 11 so
going into slide 11 what you can see is
if if the if the committee has time to
review some of the details some of the
high level Focus that we're looking at
is different platforms and so if we if
we if we jump to just for a pre brief
moment it's on slide slide six
which is department-wide strategic
initiatives and this is important
because it really does align with our
division's directions and this is what
aligns with our agency I.T plan as well
as the the Statewide strategic I.T plan
so you'll see common themes as we go
through and discuss through the budget
relationship management which is a
utilization of a platform called
Salesforce to enable us to quickly
provide applications not develop them
from scratch but leverage those
Technologies to move forward and that's
you'll hear it important as part of the
comprehensive trial welfare information
system for dcyf Medicaid quality use the
sales force New Hampshire connections
for child care registry and Licensing
uses Salesforce public health uses
Salesforce for their contact tracing
patient monitoring and case
investigation so you'll see this as a
common platform as we roll it out
continue to roll it out we have about 14
workloads on it and we anticipate at
least a dozen more in the next two years
and then we already talked about project
and resource management and data
management was really that Enterprise
business intelligence you'll hear it
called ebi I will try to always call it
Enterprise business intelligence
um care coordination is an effort that
you may have heard during the last
legislative session there were some
bills around closed loop referral and we
also had through integrated delivery
networks in the 1115 waiver from years
past inherited a solution for event
notifications and Emissions discharge
and transfer so you were talking about
that through that that through work from
Ed to New Hampshire hospital to a
designated receiving facility
potentially out into transitional
housing and then back into their home
those those tools are really
um
integral for that solution to make sure
that the referrals that are being made
by the different providers are being
received being followed up on and are
secure
as well as the emissions discharge and
transfers are timely so that people know
hey this person's coming in make sure
that you're ready for them and you have
all the information that you need so you
can actually process that admission and
or transfer so that that project the
event notification is in system is in
place and is currently growing its
network of of providers we have a little
over 144 providers on that Network
um throughout the state for health care
providers and then the closed loop
referral is in the in the RFP state
right now with the the goal of
continuing to implement it over the next
couple years so two thoughts in here
where are we at with
um the the
Master client patient index is or is
that still something we're moving
towards we've achieved we've given up on
what what's its status
it's something that we continue to
Aspire to so I would say that where
we're going to move forward on it is
when we get there's two contracts that
we're looking to move forward for
Medicaid Enterprise systems one is the
system integrator which is really the
the brain of communicating between
systems securely and managing data
governance properly as well as the
featured data analytics RFP that I was
referring to that will take us from what
we have as a master client index for the
different data sources that we ingested
our goal is to evolve that to a Master
we call it entity index so it's not just
clients but it would be for employees so
we would know we would have a golden
record for our employees and our staff
our contractors
interns as well as volunteers as well
you know I think that would just be a
good idea to like periodically volunteer
with Mr Williams to come in to talk to
oversight because that's a that's an
intersection of powerful capability to
be able to link records across systems
based on a common record ID and privacy
and I just I just think it might be
better to get that stuff into the
oversight committees the second thing I
wanted to mention uh or ask you about is
we're we're going to have some salary
and Manpower issues and so
um so this I the systems work that we're
doing that are really going to drive
efficiency and productivity
or can can they be highlighted
subsequently in a subsequent meeting so
that we can we can see the correlation
between this I.T system May save us some
ftes here
we certainly can do that and then I
would say
the challenge with right now is being
our overarching department has such a
large vacancy so it's not necessarily
saving baking saving ftes it's allowing
them to reappropriate those those
positions to do something that is now
we'll deal with that complexity okay
but we just we need to understand what
we're getting and and right now one of
the most valuable things we can get is
less pressure on our Manpower yeah and
each one of these systems has that goal
so and we if we skip into like you
requested earlier the division strategic
I.T initiatives which we can speak to
though some of those Manpower impacts
and
I would say that there won't be a single
time you'll hear me say that we're
eliminating positions but we will allow
for positions to pick up work that is
currently not being able to perform I
know it's sensitive we'll we'll figure
out how to talk nicely to each other uh
I'm just looking for we could call it
productivity gains sounds good that's
Happy
so you have a question no okay
so on the behavioral health strategic
initiatives the the big they have a
um in the drug and alcohol Services
Bureau they utilize a a tool that has
been around for many years it's called
wits or web information technology
system
and it there is a need for that system
to be upgraded and it really is a
relationship management
um solution
I'm sorry I just asked that and uh
representative Mooney says we're on
slide 14. is that correct slide 14.
slide 14. I apologize representative and
Mr chair
so on that second bullet I'm referring
to a relationship management system but
when we as I.T we try to combine
projects more possible to reduce the
impact on staff
and so we are looking to we're planning
to implement our relationship management
system and an electronic health record
system and that is one big project maybe
two separate systems or two separate
modules and certainly what um not
overlapping access but that one solution
and one project is meant to support
Hampstead Hospital New Hampshire
hospital
the behavioral health Drug and Alcohol
Services as well as potentially
supporting the forensic hospital as it
gets as it gets rolled out
and the goal the reason why we want to
do that is if we if we do it the old the
old way we would have four different
systems four different project teams
we'd be asking for resources for all
four initiatives so instead of asking
for
40 people will be looking for 10. and so
it just allows us to be more efficient
with our it Workforce and and always be
able to employ the solution that they're
looking for this little tab at the
bottom it's obviously you're doing a
color code word combination thing to
mean something what's the key on that
what are we looking at so the key on
that at the bottom is really how we
align our projects at DHHS to the
Statewide strategic Information
Technology plan that commissioner Goulet
has published and so you'll see
different themes there's strategic
partnership modern digital government
performance cyber security and
effective resource management and a lot
of those actually overlap overlap with
for our commissioner our interim
commissioner Weaver's goals so the color
inside the boxes don't add meaning they
just are categorizations to consistent
categorizations right they're really
meant to separate themselves and so like
on the behavioral health you don't
mention effective Resource Management
because it apparently doesn't tie into
that
thank you
or you might have made found a potential
error in my in my key there where I
could I could add that so in many cases
you can add all five of them what we did
is we looked at it and said here's the
three main ones that we that drove this
project forward it doesn't mean that
cyber security won't be included because
cyber security is included in every
effort that we did right I was just
looking to see if there was some color
coding here so I I know this is the
number one thing they're really trying
to achieve out of this but maybe that's
too much detail for us it was like if
you look at this key our goal is really
to modernize our systems improve the
performance of the solution that we
currently have with our our providers
that are working with Behavioral Health
and then have that strategic partnership
because it because Behavioral Health
contracts with multiple providers within
the or within the state and by
modernizing the system it and improving
that performance it actually Builds on
that strategic partnership so I mean
that that's really where we were focused
it doesn't mean that we won't
effectively resource manage our
resources and provide cyber security
solution got it
um
so then the other really the two areas
in Behavioral Health that we were
focused on is data analytics so that's a
common theme and that you'll hear
throughout conversations and and
chairman Edwards you just mentioned it
earlier lots of private sector
Industries is using data to basically
inform and provide a more knowledgeable
Direction on how
goods and services can be provided and
in private sectors for returning on
investment for us it's on providing
better better client and patient support
and services in an effective and timely
as well as cost-effective way
so we don't get that return on
investment because we don't recognize
Revenue that way but it is it is our
goal to do it the best way
and then we refer to the closed loop
referral or the care coordination
project earlier it also applies to
behavioral health here in their
strategic initiatives
the goal there is that they need a
solution so that if you arrive at a
Community Mental Health Center and they
need to provide you referrals to
clinicians to support you or they or
they or that you're going to emergency
department and you need a referral to a
community mental health center
right now it's done by phone facts and
email the goal is to make it a digital
system that we can do consent we can
maintain consent and we can understand
that that person's consented to the
services and that they're actually going
to receive services so we don't lose
track of what they're looking for in
terms of services
um so then from a timeline perspective
this is all these are major initiatives
they do take multiple years and you'll
hear at the end of if we get to the end
of the conversation that there's
procurement timelines as well as
Discovery timelines that really dictate
some of these these multi-year projects
and
so then moving on to slide 15 children
youth and Families
for the last couple years that I've been
here we've been focusing on one major
I.T system and it's the comprehensive
child welfare information system we
implemented an intake Solution on
Salesforce over the last two years and
we're working with Administration for
children and families to implement the
assessment and the case management
component of that solution this current
biennium and going into the next
biennium
this system
will be really focused on making what
their current solution is which is not a
mobile solution it's a client server
solution that they have to be on the
network in order to access the
information but when they're out in the
field supporting the The Children and
Families they don't always have an
internet connection because New
Hampshire
is New Hampshire and there are rural
areas and it's difficult to get cell
connectivity sometimes and certainly
Internet isn't even more difficult
this will allow them to go offline
still record their information and then
when they get back into an internet
connection securely transfer that
information up to the system whereas
right now those caseworkers have to do
dual entry they type it up on their
system wherever they're at either on
their pattern paper or in their computer
then when they get back they actually
have to log into the system and redo all
that work that's a huge time impact and
if you think about every case
if it adds them 20 30 minutes of
administrative effort every time they
have to do that it's taking that much
time away from the children families
they serve so that's a Major Performance
gain for those individuals
and the thought process behind
modernizing that system is that then
their caseload that they have right now
will may be more attainable as opposed
to right now it's just overwhelming
so that I'm going to skip through like
any of the details of reading this but
that's the major component of the dcyf
on site 16
economic stability strategic initiatives
so in in this division it's fairly large
but it has one of the I would say the
second largest I.T system that we have
in DHHS it's our it's called New Heights
it's our integrated eligibility system
for SNAP TANF Medicaid as well as other
Solutions utilize it for eligibility for
for services as they go forward
in as as you well know I'm sure the
federal Public Health Emergency unwind
is causing some challenges here in the
near future for us to upgrade the system
and make sure that we can make it easier
for those
um caseworkers and people and the family
assistants to answer their the calls and
process the redeterminations quicker
so you'll see major enhancements to that
system this year and then in the future
by Union we continue to enhance that one
of the things that is required on this
system is a bi-annual by it and you'll
um audit that is
extremely time consuming and
historically we would put into a capital
budget
but since it is a every two year process
it is an operating function so you'll
see that being submitted going forward
the other big system in economic
stability is child support services and
their their solution is really
processing money processing payments
making sure that the families are
receiving those payments
and they have nine plan projects I don't
have them listed here but there are nine
plan projects of enhancing that system
over the next biennium
and it is in their budget submittal that
you'll see as we go forward
um one of the key components and you'll
see that in here again is data analytics
and and the other one is document
management so data analytics is really
the standardized reporting as well as
that analytics to inform and produce
knowledge but then the document
management is really making sure that we
have
a way in which to store all of our data
securely as well as maintain retention
properly so every record in in
government has a retention period our
goal is to make sure that we can
maintain that correctly for each system
that document management initiative is
also a department-wide one but Child
Support Services leading the way on it
any questions on that one
so on slide 17 long-term supports and
services
here we have a number of different
systems but what you'll see and I hope
you'll see as we go through is that
we're starting to align towards
platforms and platforms are really
important for us to scale our I.T
infrastructure and services without
having to add more bodies and so my my
goal to support the performance of the
organization is to be able to provide
those services to enhance both the the
caseworkers and the people that are
providing services on the in the field
but also ensure that we're not overly
impacting our information technology
resources and in our our smaller
resource teams as well
so in this case when you're talking
about platforms are you talking about
the new heights platform correct so
historically New Heights has just been
focused on eligibility but you'll see
that we've expanded it this this
biennium to supporting developmental
disabilities program
and we're going to continue to expand it
to support other components of long-term
Support Services well that's good I I
just hadn't viewed it as a as a platform
uh for some reason
um that that that is a vendor supported
system that they've made some modules
that are tailored for us or or is that a
what what's the sourcing on New Heights
so new heights is a Java based
application running on in our in our
data center here at the State of New
Hampshire and it's um it is a vendor
managed solution for 100 vendor managed
solution the way they built the
eligibility workflows and the business
rules enabled it to provide the same and
very similar services to long-term
supports and services
does the vendor offer essentially the
same software solution across multiple
States or is it a unique roll your own
for New Hampshire
um I would say that when we when we
built this solution the way the contract
reads is it's it's our software it's our
solution they cannot resell it
um for their own profit however they do
develop very similar Solutions in other
states and so they do manage I think
more than half of the states
of the country's eligibility systems
um and it's and they're in various
versions of ours because we were the
first one to have an integrated
eligibility solution but they do have a
newer technology that they are deploying
as well however we have a fairly large
investment in this current solution and
we've been continuing to maintain and
operate it so that its useful life
actually is extended and so when I talk
about useful life when we we had an
opportunity to look at it and say do we
want to replace the system
and we went and looked at other states
what they were spending to replace the
system and it was upwards of 200 million
dollars and then we looked at what we
would need to do to maintain and upgrade
the system so it could meet our needs
and it was less than 10 million dollars
to do that we looked at that and said
that that's what we should do and that's
why we moved forward with the
enhancements of the existing New Height
system
and it really became a monetary thing at
that time can we meet the needs of the
department is it robust enough that it
can continue to
um support and evolve and
is it is it financially capable and it
met all three of those and so they
haven't missed a beat on any of our
enhancements and so we don't have a
challenge with those components
so with with that there are a couple
other things that long-term supports and
Services is looking to
reprocure which is including the service
link system which is like an information
and referral system for the elderly
Adult Services
and
and then as you go forward there's a
number of benefits of doing that so that
the goal is to really streamline that
we're looking at the service link system
as maybe it could could be a component
of the care coordination solution we're
not sure if it will fully hit um be
replaced by a care coordination or we'll
need to augment it
any questions on the long-term supports
of service no I've jumped ahead to
Medicaid is this is this the Investments
that we needed to make because we were
dealing with the really aged operating
systems and security vulnerabilities
were popping up and it was threatening
our ability to continue being certified
by the feds
so continuing on slide 18 Medicaid
there's two components so you're not
wrong when we did make the initiative
the investment in replacing the hardware
and software and upgrading it to current
Technologies utilizing our existing
vendor
that's actually going in place knock on
wood successfully February 11th through
the 13th to address those security and
it really wasn't security it was really
um
portability sustainability so the system
was on Old Oracle versions old old
cognos licenses old IBM Hardware all of
the vendors were saying we're not going
to support you anymore if you call us
we're going to tell you to upgrade and
so under center for Medicare and
Medicaid services requirements if we're
utilizing their funds to support our
Medicaid system we're obligated to
maintain and operate a system that is
supported by the vendors that we're
working with so they CMS supported our
our
funding for implementing the solution in
their we report to them every month on
our product productivity on implementing
so we're pretty happy about that however
the other component is that Medicaid
will CMS won't continue to fund us if we
just keep a legacy system that we
implemented in 2007. without having a
strategic review of the solution and how
does it align with their strategy for
future funding
as a result of that Discovery in working
with CMS we embarked on a re-procurement
roadmap of the mmis or Medicaid
management information system to replace
it with the Medicaid enterprise system
strategy
and what that really is is that we're
going to replace it with 12 modular
modular based Solutions and I've spoken
to a couple of those modules system
integrators one and then the data
warehouse is another or data analytics
is another
but then you'll see provider management
third party liability will be a module
financial management fiscal operations
is another one and then claims is the
largest one and so over the next five
years we have a road map of when we're
going to go out to RFP when we're going
to design develop and Implement and then
as we go live how is that going to
interface with the other systems that we
have
a couple of those claims the claims
management the data warehouse and data
analytics as well as the system
integrator instead of just implementing
it for Medicaid or implementing it for
the department so that we can do claims
processing for
dcyf through that engine as opposed to
having two separate claims processing
engines again that economies of scale
it'll cost a lot of money one time but
not a lot of money two times to do
claims processing twice it also will
reduce the amount of staff time spent on
those systems because we'll have a
unified process
so so that claims module is is going to
be attached to some other larger it
system or some other larger platform
or it's not it's not just a standalone
Enterprise service it's got to connect
to something somewhere doesn't it and
interestingly enough the industry for
claims though because of the modular
direction that CMS took and presented to
the vendor Community there are
providers out there that provide just a
claims engine that's and they can you
can buy a claims engine from them on
their environment
that will then interface with provider
management and with with our integrated
eligibility successfully and that that
is the intent of the
modular implementation is to create
those multiple service services
Enterprise level services and allow us
to get like you can call it best of
breed or best practices solutions for
people who don't know what we're just
talking about that's really cool and
exciting
I don't know if you could tell from our
voice but
go ahead
so I'm not going to really go into
details like because I already sort of
went on a high level of what the
Medicaid Enterprise strategy was to do
but there are some components that we're
we're trying to leverage to
um reduce our costs reduce our time to
delivery leveraging National Association
of State procurement officer Solutions
where they already have certified
vendors that they did RFP for eliminate
some procurement timelines
and then really you'll see in this next
24-25 where you're going to see us
implementing this system integrator
um going out to RFP and implementing the
beginning of a provider management
module and the reason why we picked
those two is the system integrators
based off of our research and working
with other states a lot of other states
started with provider which is where
usually there's some challenges and
opportunities to improve
and then they found out that they
couldn't get the provider management
solution to communicate to their
eligibility system and to all their
other systems and then they had to
essentially shut it down start over
Implement a system integrator and then
Implement a provider management so by
going a little bit later we got to learn
from the people that led the way and
made some of those errors and told us
don't do what we did do it this way and
so
that's why we're going system integrator
first for that sort of I call it the
brain it's going to tell all the arms
and legs how to work and really without
the brain you can't do a whole lot
and so we'll get that in place and then
we'll start moving on the other more
business focused Solutions
sorry you missed the punchline there
without a brain you can't do much you
can run for office
but okay so this is this is really great
I see your challenge on page 19. we're
running into trained I.T professionals
being maybe a bottleneck to a lot of
what we're doing and so you must have
some prioritization process on these 16
or so projects which one you're going to
knock out in what order
we we do and we also have
um budgetary constraints so that there
are opportunities so that the state of
New Hampshire in general
hires out most of its work outsources
the effort Outsourcing can be really
beneficial in the sense that you have
that one-time investment in the people
to help implement but it does come at a
cost and so you'll see in our budget as
it goes forward I don't know what you'll
see once it gets approved once it moves
from the governor's face to your to your
face but as that goes through we're
going to be crosswalking our submittal
to see what is in there and how does it
support us being able to achieve this
this goal and these missions
and based off of what's in the house
budget we'll be able to determine which
ones we will need to prioritize lower
and maybe put in what we call the
parking lot okay if I heard you right
it's it's it's it's like
like I was hoping you would go first
like like you would you you would go
here's the Strategic plan of the
commissioner here's the it support plan
here are all the priorities as a result
and this is how we're resource we're
going to Resource these top priorities
we're going to have a cut line where we
weren't out of resources and we start
talking about you know incremental
improvements that I was I was hoping you
guys would go in this top-down approach
but I think I just heard you say
depending on what we budget
you're going to prioritize us and do
those first and so we're sort of coming
at this
backwards from each other
so let me clarify so we did go through
during our agency phase all our
prioritization what we consider
priorities and if I put every priority
that we needed on the list we would need
a well more than our budget that we
would ever submit just like anything you
have to be reasonable with your
submittal so we went through and we
called it through and we'd say what are
these are critical and high importance
to the organization to achieve and
that's that's what we submitted forward
both to from an agency I.T plan and from
a capital budget and a operating budget
we submitted criticals and highs but
there's not a single thing on the it
list or the program list that I know of
that is like a medium or low so anything
that gets cut will have impact to
services and programs in our department
and so that that's the challenge it's
like you have to continue to evolve in
the last couple years through the
pandemic we implemented Solutions and we
have to maintain those Solutions and the
challenges when you utilize funds like
cares act and arpa funds you have to
look at now we have these great
solutions to help us Implement better
Services now we need to continue the
operating funds to support those so
you'll see those as well in the budget
but
what I was what I was referring to
representative Edwards Mr chairman was
that as you go through different phases
of a budget when there are Cuts then our
goal is to be able to understand that
those are Cuts here's the impacts and
then those are now de-prioritized
projects because that's just the part of
budgeting right and so if if there is a
cut then I'll work with the division
directors and the CFO to understand the
impact steel organization
sure I I was just wanting us in theory
to be able to help by seeing what the
priorities were and trying not to cut
the priorities so if we accidentally
inserted a budget cut somewhere that we
were doing we were looking before we
were leaping
yeah so it's
I guess we're going to come at it from
both angles we will do our best to
provide you that visibility okay
you want to skip to 22 I know that's
that's a big jump we're on
department-wide challenges sure
so we we sort of spoke to them but at
the high level department-wide
challenges are Staffing time and funding
and that pretty much is
correlates to almost everything you ever
look at but our staffing due to low
wages resulting in smaller teams really
impacts our time to deliver and what
that results in is projects that take
years instead of like three years
instead of one year or months instead of
weeks and so in many cases there are
solutions that we could Implement rather
quickly but without the resources we
can't and so that's
one of the biggest challenges I would
say the division directors would say
that they have with me as well as they
have with information Technologies we
don't have the staff to support their
continuous needs to to meet legislative
mandates to meet um current their
clients and their providers and their
patients needs and the individuals of
our state's needs and so then they
create workarounds
um and then
so then the the timelines and I sort of
sort of I spelled this out a little bit
is in order to do some of these major
efforts and it takes Discovery so we
need to work with what we call subject
matter experts
and we need it business analysts and
project managers to work with them to
really understand what do they need and
then translate that into a requirements
so that we can then build a good project
a good project plan good scope and a
good contract to then either Outsource
or that would be the contract way or in
source with our current resources right
so so I'm I'm the the first words under
Staffing on page 22 Patrician due to low
wages okay so
if you were to quantify that uh what how
low is too low are we you know 20 below
Market five percent below Market how
where where are we
um I'll take that one because I see it
across the I.T across the state um it
really depends on the roles what we did
see is is Major
um major wage inflation in the areas
that are most in demand which includes
all of the things that DHHS is doing so
the you know the platforms like
Salesforce the electronic business
intelligence those are the those uh
cyber security those are the hottest
talents in there and during covet
particularly wage inflation was very
significant in those areas so it varies
by area but but we're we're particularly
for uh in the areas that um David's
talking about where you're looking for
business analysts project managers
um and um and sometimes developers or
senior Architects
um we're very significantly below Market
um like way more than 20 percent
could be 100 or more way more you just
said it could be as much as a hundred
percent so we're paying I guess I know
some roles in my team where we are a
third of market right now so as I
understand the governor is preparing a
Statewide
salary fix uh for this budget that he's
going to talk to us about and it's going
to be in the budget
uh I I can't I I can't imagine him
saying is it do you
I'll just be quiet on that I I I I I
don't know how to repair something that
that's got such a huge differential well
I think anything is going to be helpful
and and a lot of us don't come and do
our jobs
with the money
um and so there there really is the to
me for example I you know uh I could
earn a lot more out in the private
sector but I really like I love my job
and I love doing what I'm doing so
there's there's that aspect to it I know
um you know so in my private sector
roles we were motivated by stock options
and bonuses and things like that but
what I use as a motivation is citizen
service you know that fulfillment you
get so when you're implementing a system
I try not to talk about it in terms of
hey you just put this technology in you
just made the line shorter at DMV you
just you know you just did this really
huge thing for the benefits of the
citizens of New Hampshire you know so a
lot of the things that that I try to do
is explain it in that context so I
believe we'll always be below work and
we have to be you know there's a certain
Tipping Point where you know if you're
too far below you might have a real
problem and I think we've hit that but
but
um I I do believe that what um what's
being proposed will help particularly on
retention but there's just a
um
and I do believe that you know we'll
continue to have that balance between
using you know outside contract
resources to deliver on big system
implementations as well as uh State
staff to to run you you'll always need
State staff to do the top level
management the contracts management
things like that so so uh in an era of
rapidly Rising wage uh requests I I
would I would think that the contract
route would be more successful to
inflationary pressure than what we could
do with salaries
does that make sense does that is that
your experience the contracts are going
up faster than if we if we were to build
staff in-house
um well contractors you know there's two
things it it is it's if you're going to
if you're a system integrator you're
going to have to hire at Market you have
no choice or you won't have people
particularly in the hot areas so if
there is wage inflation there then when
they bid on contracts they will account
for that ins inside their bids there's a
little bit of a perverse effect too
that's happening where we see some if we
have a good contract in place or I say
good is now you know we had some
competitive pre-covered wages that still
exist those are challenging because the
motivation to actually do the job is in
some cases is diminished by the system
integrator because their profit margins
may have shrunk to you know quite a lot
in um based on the fact that that we
locked them in you know and I say a
three or five year deal and now they're
you know you've pre-covered weight rates
in there so so that is a interesting
effect that we're seeing as well where
there's less motivation to service an
existing contract
or Mooney
thank you very much and thank you for
your presentation today obviously very
detailed because the work you do is so
thorough uh getting to slide 17 in a
nutshell I know that vendors will always
propose the latest and the greatest
updates and software and programs and so
on and so forth in a nutshell what is
the state's procedure process to be sure
we're getting exactly what we need and
we're paying for exactly
the item that a vendor could give us to
make sure we're delivering the best
Services I can imagine it's difficult to
weed through a lot of marketing and
Promises
yes you you really get into the
procurement process there
um so it's one of the reasons why it
takes us a while is because we're we
really are careful and DHHS is
particularly careful
um as we go through the the process of
procurement to look at to validate that
what we've asked for so it starts in the
beginning right you have to ask for what
you need
and and that takes a lot of work you
know you would think it'd be easy right
what do you need but that Discovery
process is can be pretty lengthy if you
do that well then at least you have a
procurement that if fulfilled will get
the business folks what they need in the
end then there's the process of
evaluating the responses and parsing out
those responses to make sure that you
are actually going to get what you need
and then you've you have to hold this uh
the supplier accountable once you're you
know so you award the contract you go
through the governor and Council process
you you kick off the project it's really
important to have that relationship with
your partner who's who's delivering to
make sure that they are holding up their
end meeting the terms of the agreement
so it's it's a pretty and we we all
together spend a lot of time on that yep
and then that's both for delivery
perspective from a cyber security
perspective from a from a privacy
perspective all of that
okay thank you are there other questions
so anyone in the attendance feel like
you want to say anything after all of
this
no
um Mr Ripple
So based on today
I I think I think we need to find at
least a three-hour block to continue a
work session on HP 49.
you you're probably way ahead what what
do you got well I haven't uh talked to
Janet about it or scheduled anything yet
I don't I was waiting to see what days
you thought uh might be best you already
have
pretty much a full day of work scheduled
for Thursday the 9th so I'm not sure
before the ninth okay
um
well anything that we try to schedule
now will not appear in the calendar in
that case
I you know as as much as I love the
calendar at this point I I want to make
sure that we have an opportunity to
complete the conversation okay and I and
so whatever the rules are I want to
comply with the rules but you know
so do you think Wednesday would be a
good day to meet in that case well uh I
had thought we I had reserved the eighth
because I thought initially that was
when Finance was going to meet so so
it's probably Wednesday the 8th is
probably open for me uh is it open for
you I see you not in your head
representative erf and tlerski walner go
ahead
on the 8th it on my calendar it says we
have a 10 45 in finance and then I have
a bill to introduce as a prime sponsor
at 145.
okay
I I can check on 104. we can find a room
to work in right because we're a smaller
group we don't need all this space
oh okay let's let's shoot for that now
go ahead representative walner
clerk but how do we how do we have a
work session
a division work session without having
it posted someplace and I can't remember
the details of how we do that or what we
do about that
I I I'm looking for Mr Ripple's advice
well I'll have to check on what the
current rules are Wednesday would meet
the 48-hour notice requirement I don't
know if that's still in effect
um I'd have to check on whether there's
whether there's a current requirement
that everything be calendared I'm not
sure about that I don't believe there is
I think there was an expectation that
there was going to be less certainty in
this session
than in previous sessions okay
reassess this
yeah I don't think you you're already
out of the work session on House Bill 49
so I don't think you can recess this
until okay all right well one I'll uh I
think we can leave you alone you know
what the intent is we want to we want to
do it Wednesday we want to do it within
the rules maybe in the other order we
want to do it within the rules if we can
do it Wednesday that would be great but
I but I would like us to have reached a
conclusion before we go to full Finance
on the ninth
so
thoughts
I I just think we should
figure out what the rule is and how we
get that done and then
schedule a time I I think we've agreed
that we're going to first comply with
the rules with the idea that we're going
to schedule on Wednesday and then miss
Ripple is going to let us know if that's
doable or not doable
okay uh anything else uh I thought I had
something I got an invite from somebody
got an invite from Commerce
on for Wednesday at 9 00 A.M
they're bringing in somebody who's an
expert on Pharmacy benefit managers and
the reason why pbm's may be interesting
to division three is because even though
it's an insurance kind of issue the pbms
end up to be really Central to the
overall levers on drug costs and with as
much emphasis as there are on drug costs
understanding if you don't know anything
about pvms this would be you know
basically a tutorial set up for that
very purpose so so we're invited on the
ninth excuse me on Wednesday at 9 A.M to
Commerce
it's not required it's just an invite
anything before
from the members I I don't want to I
don't want to close without Ripple in
the room just in case uh he's coming
back with like the last minute Intel
hey thank you for coming and a good
presentation a lot of depth a lot of
detail I I'm sort of left you know
believing though that when the
commissioner comes out with her
strategies I'm not going to be able to
lay the I.T strategies next to it and
see an alignment that there's still that
they'll probably be a way to make an
alignment but I was kind of hoping for
something
simple
and I'll let you think about it
yeah you will do our best to make to do
that alignment for you and Nathan and I
were just talking about some strategies
about how to do that so that that'd be
great I I don't it would be useful to me
maybe useful to the committee maybe
useful to the fiscal committee and I
don't know internally I hopefully that
wouldn't be wasted effort that it may
get some use for your team
I think it would be very good to have
those those dotted line connections so
that we can show here's the program area
here's what we're doing for our
initiatives and our our roadmap for our
our next year and next biennium and how
does that align to the technology
initiatives that's really important
component so thank you it certainly
sounds good so Mr White before we leave
you got anything for us
I think I think when we were just
chatting offline one of the things you
and Mr Ripple are going to do
yes
um so earlier we we were we were
discussing what what the future schedule
would look like once the governor's
budget does come out
um I'll be working with Kevin over the
next couple of days just to figure out
uh when Medicaid will come when dltss
will come what are the days that we need
to block out I think there's a holiday
in there as well of the legislative
Break
um so we will we'll be working offline
and we'll follow up soon just to make
sure that those the times that we
propose work with everybody's schedules
in in one of the boundary conditions we
were hoping to meet if possible not
required but if possible that week where
it's down for the house we're trying to
leave Thursday and Friday open so that
people can at least have a long weekend
on that week
do you know what I'm saying
okay are you saying for our division
only or for everyone if you read the
house calendar there's a there's a
little blurb in there that says that you
know we're going to shut down for or no
no house sessions on that week right so
that's kind of code for if the
Committees does don't have work you can
take some time off I just assumed we
would have worked no we're going to have
a ton of work which is why I'm giving
you an update we're trying to work it so
that we can maybe keep Thursday and
Friday of that week reserved so that at
least you got a long weekend
great that's that's that's the objective
I don't know if we're going to succeed
Mr Ripley what do you got for us I was
just going to mention on the house bill
49 issue there's no requirement that the
meeting be in the calendar
um so it could be scheduled for
Wednesday did you have a particular time
in mind
10 A.M
okay yeah because I I want people who
want to accept Commerce invitation on
the pbms to have the opportunity to go
you got anything else for us Mr White
long day no words of wisdom today other
than bundle up okay Miss Santa Nella
what did we get right what did we get
wrong you you've been watching a lot
today
okay
all right okay well thank you and then
um with that um
this work session of division three is
adjourned